want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
youtube you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
amazing motivation from the one and only
brendan burchard enjoy
the first lesson today in about sort of
having patience for your dream is you
have to work on it every single day for
at least 30 minutes
or don't fool yourself that it's gonna
happen
you know we all hope that one day we'll
get a bunch of free weekends or a month
off or three months off and that's when
we'll finally start working towards our
thing you got to do it every day where
that means you research every day you
read every day you study every day you
take a course every day or you actually
create everything on that thing every
day you're just working at it book
authors they write every day not all of
them but a lot of the greats wrote every
single day right and it's just forcing
ourselves
to really be in the game now not
everybody writes every day not even
needs to create every day some people
can just have a marvelous 18 days and
they've written the greatest book of all
time but that rarely happens
it rarely happens and those folks tend
to be like masters or savants or
geniuses regular folks myself included i
got to work every day towards my dreams
every day i honed in something about
this and if you didn't know something
about me i do everything in this
business right i'm shooting this video
right now but i mean i picked the
materials for this thing i chose the
fonts i designed all the pages i mean i
wrote the back cover the front cover the
inside stuff it's like i do the projects
of
my dreams and that's what keeps me
creatively fired up and engaged you know
research studying psychology found out
that both second person and third person
makes you more
it makes yourself talk more powerful so
if you're gonna do affirmations you
wouldn't just say i wanna do this i
wanna do this you wanna do what we call
in the book self-coaching
where you would say you know in my case
yeah
brendan it's important you do a good job
here today because you usually don't do
interviews and you really love marie and
you want to do a good job for her and
her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well and brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky brendan
that's a different level of going i'm
lucky i'm lucky right it is i'm brendan
yes another one another one i do every
morning yeah assuming i take a shower
but every morning the shower because we
all don't every day not every morning no
we do not just doesn't happen it does
not happen i told you like 24 hours ago
i was staying in a barn in the woods at
a friend's house
but the second thing i asked myself in
the in the shower every morning is
what might happen today that could trip
me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that brendan
i say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate you know something's going to
go wrong during the day absolutely and
if i already know everything like like
this morning's was okay
you're in
i think what we would i think i'm yes
north manhattan where i'm staying would
you call it north you're uptown i'm
uptown and you're coming to um let's
just call it downtown okay so i'm like
okay that's going to be
45 minutes it's a hot summer day yes
i'm gonna get hot and i know when i'm
hot sometimes i get impatient yes and i
get stressed and i don't want to feel
that so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with marie brendan
and really just engage pay attention be
present with new york and really enjoy
that you're here i know that sounds
completely crazy but every
high-performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it i mean at high level
every person i interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers they all
self-talk and most of them we found
we're doing it in second and third
person which is amazing i love it yeah i
think it's so fun yeah little things
yeah so if you already talk to yourself
and you say your name to yourself
they're not crazy you're probably high
performing outside of teaching people to
bring the joy in my life
i teach people to honor the struggle
honor the difficulty
when we honor the struggle instead of
hate the struggle
we can really achieve extraordinary
things because our mindset's in the
right place it accept like as soon as
you honor the struggle you accept that
oh of course there should be struggle
here i should i should honor this
process when you go to the gym to work
out you like honor that this is going to
be hard and it honored that process of
getting better and the more that you
bring honor to it the more your psyche
builds with strength and you get a
little bit of that esteem back
because you see yourself engaging
something versus avoiding it and running
away
you see yourself connecting with
something and giving it
reverence
you're like like i have reverence for
the difficulties of life they may be
better
so i don't want a friction free life i'm
not interested in it you know the the
the i like to say sometimes that you
know
the journey to greatness begins
the moment that
our you know deep desires for comfort
and ease
are overpowered
by our desires to connect and contribute
so in terms of clarity what is that
habit that you take on on a daily or
monthly basis with habit with clarity
what do you think about you're like
every morning what am i clear about or
yeah you know how do you apply that
habit to your life i apply in a couple
ways
first for me
every situation i go into
i'm consistently asking like what what's
the feeling i want to
have here if you ever see me teach it's
often i always say bring the joy
so i have joy triggers that i've set up
in my mind that makes me more
intentional about things so for example
a door frame trigger whenever i walk
through a door i say bring the joy
so when i walk through that door right
there it's like bring the joy into this
room
it's just it's just a mental trigger
that i've set up for myself every
morning in the shower i ask myself three
questions
and not that i shower every morning
the first question i say what can i be
excited about today
so it forces me to be clear about what's
going to draw joy enthusiasm for me
number two i say
what might trip me up today
because usually i know what's going on
today i'm like what might mess me up
what my where might i perform well what
might bother me and number three i say
what can i do to surprise somebody today
to give a gift of appreciation or
acknowledgement today and so i think
through that in the morning so i think
that helps me begin my day pretty clear
um then when i sit down before i do work
i literally look at my calendar of the
day this morning
and i look at whatever's going on the
day and i think about it for 20 minutes
it's one of my 20-minute routines in the
morning i literally
think about my calendar
for 20 minutes a day people think that's
crazy
but what i'm thinking through when i'm
looking to count i'm like okay i'm gonna
have that call
what do i want to happen on that call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do i want
to end that call you know i'm gonna have
that time with louis like how do i want
to be there and and how can i make sure
i enjoy it because it's a big deal you
know i love your show i want to do a
good job i want to share something good
for the people even though i have no
idea what you're going to ask
right
i want to be present for that and and
make sure i i'm i'm really there even
though maybe i have a head cold today
you know it's like it's like just
thinking through it i think
that helps me
it keeps me asking questions every
sunday
i do a life arenas assessment that just
means i think there's 10 areas of our
life
and i score myself in them
and this is about my 11th year of doing
this wow so each area of my life you
know from
from emotional quality to happiness to
relationships to time to hobby et cetera
i just give myself a score of one to ten
and one means i suck
and i i was horrible in the previous
week on that ten means i did a good job
and then i ask how can i do better it's
my sunday routine yeah and it just keeps
me clear
and it's not like i don't
sometimes like everyone else you know
wonder what's going on or what i'm doing
but
those habits
those were my habits you have to
establish your own for seeking clarity
but when you have them
you weaponize your life transitions
takes place in
the chapter of generate energy and also
maybe it's in productivity too uh and it
has this converse it's just a
conversation
that if you're go go go go all the time
you're depleting energy all day and you
don't know it and lots of people think
to get more energy or more productive
they have to radically change your life
i'd better work out an extra 60 minutes
in the morning it's like actually let me
teach you the mastery of managing
transitions when you go from one
activity
to another i want to teach you this
simple thing and that is release tension
set intention
very simple let me give you an example
because it really helps if you're doing
email and you know that that takes one
part of you your your psyche and brain
to do a lot of email and now you're
gonna go create that keynote or that
powerpoint presentation that you want to
be flowing and visual and beautiful very
different things what most people do is
they'll do their email and then they'll
work a little on the presentation then
the notification come over here and
they'll go back to the email and then
they're multitasking
and they're wrecking not only their
measurable creativity but their
long-term performance and so what you
have to do is
when you finish the email stop it
okay maybe go get some water come back
or whatever even if you don't only do
push away from your chair for a minute
close your eyes
repeat the word release
with
the goal of releasing tension in your
body
and repeat the word release yourself
several times over and over like a
mantra okay just three p it could be 60
seconds it could be one minute it can be
two minutes or whatever you want to do
just do it until you feel like your body
and your mind release a little bit
then
before you open your eyes set an
intention say okay
brendan you're going to work on this
keynote now your intention is to make
something that grabs them right at the
beginning and then make it really move
fast and make it um
make it visual and make sure that it
builds emotionally throughout the thing
so when you make a call to action at the
end bam
and then open my eyes now work on
presentation
i'm clean and free from the previous
activity yes and people will feel an
unbelievable amount of energetic just
power come back from there i interviewed
or i've worked with
uh a major founder in the startup
silicon valley world flew me down at 3
00 am and
i guess it was around after midnight on
private jet it was just great he was
having a lot of trouble just exhausted
literally depleted um you know this
person's incredibly well valued in this
company lots of employees everyone knows
who the person would be
but miserable
just go go go go go
and i said what's go and one of his
major things was he was wrecking his
relationship with his wife and his
children
beca not because he was
maybe just overworking he would just
carry a lot of the work into his house
yep so when i say i said i want you to
pull up to your house
after the day of working don't get out
of the car
pull up the pull up the house
just close your eyes repeat the mantra
release yourself maybe five minutes
and then before you open your eyes set
the intention how do you want to be with
your wife when you enter
the house
what kind of dad do you want to be to
your daughter
just set that intention
open up your eyes now go in as a
different man
and it changed his life his email to me
is in the beginning
it's fantastic it just works that means
just release tension yep set intention
it's just your transitions are where
most people is bleeding out their energy
and they don't know and if we can just
get you four or five times of transition
really well throughout the day you
finish your day like i feel amazing yes
and we didn't we didn't caffeinate you
we didn't do anything we just changed
how you approach your work get up in the
morning i drink 20 ounces of water
i do 20 minutes of mobility movement and
stretching every morning
then i read for 20 minutes something
positive for me it's almost always a
self-help book or a leadership book
almost always sometimes a business book
almost always self-help and leadership
read that book then
i
go and i sit down
with my high performance planner
my green tea i fill out the day
right i look at the blocks of time that
are already scheduled
and then what i use is my second
visualization which is i look at the
major blocks of time that have been
scheduled just like this this morning
and i close my eyes
and i think
how do i do that thing with excellence
what would make that thing
special
so this morning before i got here when i
thought about this because there's my
high performance planner impact theory
tom bilyeu oh yes three exclamation
points literally so i looked at the
schedule it closed my eyes and i thought
okay
what do i want to communicate on tom's
show how do i want that to feel
what do i want to communicate so i
literally close my eyes and i visualize
those blocks of time
and how would i do them well that's a
superpower most people write their day
out and they just go about the day and
then they sometimes they come back to
the plan and they go oh my god i didn't
even do it
because i sit there and i think about
how do i do that well
that's the game changer what does that
rebuilding process look like for
somebody who's trapped in depression and
suicidal thoughts yeah
um
i've been there a lot
in my life uh especially
before my car accident my teenage years
then the first woman i ever loved we had
a
big breakup
and that breakup sent me down in
depression and suicidal planning
and
it's tough to dispense advice to people
other than get help and i'll share why
because that time in my life i had so
many people coming up to me
you know my friends would come into my
dorm room
let's go do something and you just
there's just
the hope is lost and what people i think
make the mistake of trying to do is hype
people up
everything's gonna be okay you're gonna
be great
and what people need who are suicidal is
serious psychological intervention they
need to seek support and help and
outside of that
when they do get that support
the first thing a great therapist is
going to do outside of the emotional
reflection work of why are you here and
what has caused this sort of pattern for
you they're going to get you starting to
get some momentum
the most important thing is when you are
super down
outside of finding that emotional
reasoning for where you are
is to start getting momentum because
with momentum comes hope with momentum
comes motivation with momentum comes
you know that feeling that there's a
reason for tomorrow
and so it's as simple as just saying
okay what are three things i'm gonna do
today
and
i don't mean that like a lot of personal
development guys would say like what are
your three big goals for the day
i'm like dude sometimes that first goal
is shh i'm gonna shower today
i'm really in shower today uh
i'm gonna walk to the library
and come home
and that's all they got
like literally that's all they got
and you gotta honor that struggle when
you're in that place like know that
where you're at it is okay that you're
there and now you're gonna need help and
now you're gonna have to set up some
daily practices just every day win a
little bit
not like win your dreams not like crush
through goals not like me badass not
like no
just momentum man
you know most of the guys i've dealt
with
in that position who were suicidal
outside of their therapeutic work i said
the most important thing you can do is
win the morning
just win the morning man i think that's
true for all of us even high performers
like i if i don't have my morning
routine game
i feel you know out of sorts um so i
think it's true for everybody you gotta
own your morning you gotta win it
because that starts and sets up
everything else i know you believe that
as well like people need that discipline
those routines that will help the rest
of their day go better
um
and
i don't wanna ever be flippant with the
advice to people who are dealing with
that situation outside of get some help
get some momentum and be okay if that
momentum is really small
because it will build trust that that
momentum builds and trust those
gloomy and bad dark days
trust that those are going to be there
they'll get less and less and less as
you learn how to cope but they're going
to be there high performers develop
influence
more than those around them it's not
because they're cool it's not i mean
look at me
i'm not getting ahead of my cool factor
here ladies and gentlemen i just got
these these new nikes
i walk in the stores like
what's your newest shoe they're like
these ones i'm like i need that and
they're like wow i'm like because lewis
has sneaks man i got i i wear suits or
like i'm either on stage in a suit or or
at my you know studio kind of like you
know kind of formal too sure um i was
like man i gotta get some sneak stuff
i said give me your newest sneaker so
i'm not getting a head on the cool i
don't develop influence because i'm cool
it's not your personality that gives you
influence it's how you treat other
people and specifically the way that
people high performers gain influence
is is this way too much no i'm i'm you
know get it how do you develop here's
how you do here's how you develop
influence
if you really want high level of
influence
obviously you got to do all the basics
treat people nice be kind and in the
book what i do is with each habit i say
here's the basics
but then i go here's what the
needle-mover practices are
the highest performing influencers what
they're doing often they don't know
they're doing it by the way
the first thing they're doing is they're
teaching people how to think
a lot of your show
gained influence i really believe
because you're really good at teaching
people how to think you're shaping their
mindset
but high performers are really doing it
uh explicitly and you do this too where
you say
here's how to think about that guys or
high-performing leaders tell their team
here's how we should be thinking about
ourselves here's how we should be
thinking about the competition here's
how we think about the future of the
company they're saying it they're
explicit more often here's how to think
i mean the the what is it the seventh
most read book in the history of the
world
is think and grow rich
crazy it became that way because he
taught people how to think about money
we have to tell our audience how to
think about things
the second thing they're doing is
they're challenging people
and they're challenging the specific way
if you listen to great orators great
speaker
the pros when i know i'm like oh this
person studied speech before
is they challenge the audience in three
ways they challenge the audience's
character
then they challenge the audience's
connections their relationships then
they challenge the audience's
contributions what they're giving
you hit all three of those the audience
is like i have to listen to her i have
to listen to him because not only are
they shaping how i should be thinking
because maybe i was thinking wrong
but now they're pushing me because you
know just like a great coach the
greatest coaches
they're not just saying throw the ball
better they're like louis you're a
better man than that come on man
they're saying look you're treating your
team like crap they look look you're not
contributing the team here that's a
different challenge than just throw the
ball faster or catch the you know
so i studied that from them but those
are the primary things and the third
thing of course is role modeling
you know standing i mean if i'm the
bring the joy guy or i'm the honor the
struggle guy or i'm the high performance
guy and i'm off my game
people are gonna know that yeah
so that's i'm always trying to role
model what i do which is hard when
you're talking about high performance
because everyone thinks well don't you
have a bad day i'm like dude
i have bad moments i would say bad days
because yeah i don't want to go to bed
and feel like the day was bad
um
but at the same time i think
that's why they're developing influence
high performers are not dissatisfied
strivers
they're not they're happy high
performers are happier than their peers
we all believe that to get the top it's
gonna be lonely at the top and we all
believe you have to grind and kill
yourself to get there yeah and that's
completely wrong and the data proves it
worldwide
which is i think just overcoming a lot
of people's biases about how you work
today because right now
especially today like you know grind on
social media is so popular or hustle or
hustle and it by the way none of the top
15 percent of high performers worldwide
identify with those words
they literally don't we asked them we
did a whole keyword analysis yep this
was actually pretty cool and high
performers explicitly say these these
are three driving feelings if we said
there was a high performance state it's
driven from these three things number
one full engagement yes number two
joy yes
and number three confidence yes that's
what they relate with okay that's where
it's coming from it's a joyous journey
not a dissatisfied one and this i had
this conversation in the book um
because
uh uh i kind of maybe
frame it this way each of these chapters
opens with a vignette
of somebody i worked with or a situation
that i was in that demonstrated high
performance in this particular situation
i'm walking on stage
thousands of people
after a very famous musician was out
there and was telling the audience that
that person's secret to success remember
thousands of people yes their secret to
that person their whole speech their
secret to success was
never settle
never settle nothing is enough never
settle and never be satisfied never be
satisfied always demand more and i'm
like oh
my second slide which is gonna be on
jumbotrons in like 80 point text
was strive satisfied i'm like oh i'm
gonna have to dispel this for all these
thousands of people i was totally
freaked out yeah and but what i had to
explain to people was not only the data
but it's this
uh
if you're never satisfied
i mean what is it true that life is
precious
if it's true that life is precious and
you could be gone tomorrow do you really
want to think you know what i just never
felt fulfilled
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of credit
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of peace i never allowed myself to look
at that and say good job
that's not the way to live life right i
think just at a spiritual level it's a
bad move and this book doesn't really go
in a lot of that it's more about the
science and the heart stuff
but i think it's really important that
people realize
your job is to strive satisfied and if
you strive satisfied more often
you will be more of a high performer and
if you never give yourself credit you're
always beating up on yourself you're
always thinking that's not perfect
enough
then what's going to happen
dissatisfied people burn out and they
quit
more often
than satisfied strivers so take joy in
the moment
engage with what you're doing
allow credit and satisfaction enjoy to
come in you can always be improving of
course but be proving be improving
joyfully yes and if you're improving
joyfully then you're learning you feel
curious you feel engaged
the joy is there you'll get more
confident because you're like i'm gonna
learn through this anyway this would be
great
because you know this
this thing is all over social media
right now like
you know grind work whatever and i'm
like
it's just it's popular and i see why
that happens and i see why it's catchy
it's just not scientifically valid yeah
i think a big
development growth point for people is
determining
how do i really want to treat people
when they don't agree with me
or when they're hating on me
or when they're discounting me or
they're being mean to me or we're in a
fight
because i think some of those are the
greatest growth areas of our life at the
end of our lives
if we have a moment of cognition we're
going to lay there in bed
and
we're going to ask questions about our
life to evaluate whether or not we were
happy with it
and what i've always suggested to people
is
maybe don't pretend you're living your
purpose unless you know
the questions you're going to ask at the
end of your life how do you evaluate it
because otherwise you're just kind of
living randomly but when you know oh i'm
going to evaluate my life this way at
the very end now every day you can wake
up with intention now every day you get
to wake up with purpose which is why i
love the name of your show because
that's my thing too
it's like
this this deep connection to some type
of purpose so that at the end of our
life we're happy there's no regrets
there there's no sadness there's no oh
my gosh why was i this way or why did i
wait to do that
and i my unique story
is that i got that gift at 19
years old people should want to have a
high level of joy and happiness in their
life yeah
but they cannot they cannot wait for it
i always say you know the power plant
doesn't have energy
it generates energy i mean technically
it transforms energy from one medium to
another and we can do the same thing
you know you don't have happiness you
have to generate the happiness you don't
have joy
you generate joy and when you learn to
take control of your power and your
energy in that way
then life becomes so much more
fulfilling and so much more fun and it
doesn't become fake or forced because
you know it's fake and forced
this all day yeah that's not your
natural state yeah i mean and here's how
you know take a person uh you know i
just got back from a big vacation with
my lady and and we were down on the
beach and and through take any person
put them on a beach for a while and
they're not like
your natural state is like this is
beautiful this is great there's awe
there's inspiration there's joy there
tap back into that and you'll be more of
a high performer i love it it's so
simple
like when you get the life is really
short and you felt that before either by
you were threatened or you've had
someone your dear near and dear die but
when you have that real essence in you
that says life is short have reverence
for it live it that's a really big thing
i got that at 19 and i learned
specifically
that
if we have a moment of cognition before
the end of our life
we tend to
ask questions to evaluate if we're happy
so if i have any impact in the world
it's
going to come from that experience where
i learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine
what the questions you're going to ask
at the end of your life are going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life
to evaluate your life
so that you would know if you were happy
with your life like figure out those
questions
and then live each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end
for me the answers the questions i had
were did i live
which i hadn't i hadn't been living my
life i'd been thinking about taking my
life
did i love
no my heart was broken
and i put up all these walls to keep out
other people and i always say you know
sometimes the walls we put up to keep up
the bad guys prevent the good guys from
getting in
and suddenly in our own self-protection
we block out the very thing we want
which is connection
and i learned that i would ask did i
matter
you know 22 years ago
on a dark caribbean night i'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
bleeding out
my friend
and i just wrecked a car he's screaming
at top of his lungs he's bleeding we
know if we're going to live
and i'm standing on this car
looking down all this blood
and i'm in
terror
and i just remember looking down at the
hood and just thinking
did i even matter
you know
and i hated the answer at that time in
life
because a 19 year old kid i didn't know
about impact theory
for real i didn't know to think about
that you some you know young kids
sometimes they don't know to think about
that i didn't know to think about
legacy
meaning
did i matter i didn't think i did
but the good news is
i'm a good learner
and i felt like i got a second chance
from god that night and
i learned
that it was really important for me
to figure out how do i live and how do i
love and how do i matter in such a way
that if i face my death again i'll know
i've earned the second chance
and so what i want to tell people and
the impact i want is i just want people
to know know your questions man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because this moment's
a blessing so earn this moment and live
intentionally demonstrate
courage
and i think all personal development
people of course you know
but they actually high performers do
demonstrate courage like we can measure
it from peer feedback we can measure it
from their self-assessments we can
measure it from we have this thing
called the high performance indicator
assessment you take it you get scored on
all six habits it's free on the internet
um on the interwebs um
but this one
peaked when we did the research and i
didn't know it and it is high performers
are more willing
to
share their ideas
their thoughts their feelings
what they need what they want
and they do it more consistently than
their peers even when there's risk or
uncertainty
you do a great job i know you have the
books coming out for you
talking about men and being vulnerable
that's demonstrating courage that's
you know when you're not conditioned
that way or you're not used to that you
know that it might not seem like a big
deal but it it is yeah you know um when
you talked about me doing this interview
that was like it might not seem like
demonstrating courage to go on lewis
house but it is because i admire you
and i also
i'm not used to sharing a lot you know
you just let the work speak for itself
yeah so i had to like okay i need to
share
you know be willing to share this in
different and unique ways
but i think for most people it's
when you're in your last meeting
did you share your ideas and fight
them for yourself you share your ideas
do
for
and fight for them
when you wanted to post that video and
you were scared to death because people
are gonna make fun of you did you do it
and
when you wanted to tell your spouse that
you're not getting what you need
did you say it
because all those are demonstrating
courage it's not just you know
courage we think you're pulling someone
out the river or something and that's
part of it the human brain has an
incredible capacity for guilt
and most people unconsciously let that
roll over them and kick their butt and
make a horrible life i love guilt guilt
is a tool guilt is a weapon guilt does
not have to be a bad thing it's not like
i perpetuate but i'm like i love that i
feel bad when i don't do a good job
most people hate that about themselves i
love that feeling i'm like
i didn't do a good job there next time i
will
so some people
guilt is discouragement
other people it's a signal for learning
to me guilt is a signal for learning it
is the body and the brain the spirit
knowing what is right knowing what is
wrong knowing what's great knowing
what's mediocre and saying hey do a
little better now if it's translated
into a negative impulse then some people
call it guilt but i'm like i'm totally
cool with that i you know i think it's
good that we feel bad
when we do something that is below our
standard or
that's not right
because that impulse to go i want to do
that better stage one was i
was honest
that i was a hot mess
like i came back from the accident and
i'm like i'm a mess i've been depressed
i was gonna kill myself
i'm sad my grades suck my friends are
kind of like losers uh you know not in a
judgmental way to them but in how i
wanted to feel they made me feel bad
about myself
and that's why i think a loser isn't
what they've accomplished it's how they
make other people feel
two different things they made me feel
bad
and i thought i
i don't have it together
and that began my great and long-term
committed search to studying psychology
because i'm like why do i think so dumb
why do i feel so bad about myself how do
you overcome
you know depression how do i deal with
this sadness
why do i still have so much hatred in my
heart about something that happened so
long ago like just all this
like people say forgiveness how do you
do that i remember seeing this way back
oprah had oprah.com
and i thought how cool would be to have
your name
dot com
now
i sought this kid out so i went to
brendan.com and this guy he had his
resume up there
and that's all he had was a resume so i
emailed the guy and i'm like hey man i
really love to own this website
um could i buy it from me he goes no
it's my name like dang it
and he says uh no you know i got my mom
she's got you know an email we have an
email associated with the domain right
all this stuff i said oh man
all right
every so i set it my calendar every six
months for six years whoa
my calendar would go off and i'd email
him again
email him again email him again email it
took six
years and with sixth year he said you
know what yeah you know i i'd be
interested in that conversation
sold it so i got brendan.com i'm really
happy about that really thrilled that
stupid story but i was like yes
determination um
i found this quote um
that said you know the journey to
greatness
often begins the moment
that
challenge and contribution
become more important than comfort and
ease that's a good one yeah that's
really good and so we have to challenge
ourselves but the habit here the social
habit
is develop influence and you develop
influence teach me how to think role
model away and then make sure that you
are challenging people in those three
hours challenge their character you got
to do that delicately the book teaches
you how make sure you challenge
relationships because that's so
important and challenge people's what
they're giving and if you do that
strategically enough you know part of
your message in greatness is challenging
people
to follow their dreams you say it all
the time it's one reason i love your
show
you're constantly challenging people to
follow their dreams and not just like
hey follow your dreams like hey do this
i want to learn to be confident
i want to learn how to communicate well
and i want to learn to have great
relationships
so i studied those things really
intensely and i just tried them and i
tried them and i just i literally i was
so good about making little goal sheets
and trying and that was the year i also
began my monthly goals
so on the first day of every month to
this day
i write a personal goal and a
professional goal um that is the outside
of all the things that project i'm
trying to achieve
the personal goal is something like
be more patient this month and every day
i look out on the way out i put on the
door i'd walk out and be patient no
matter what my other goals or objectives
or that was like the defining personal
theme so i created monthly challenge
themes
for 23 years
you know patients have come up a lot of
times
it's like joy has come up a lot of times
yes you know uh staying centered has
come up a lot of times it's not like i
have ever achieved i've no one achieves
personal development i agree or a
purpose
it is like
an intention
and a dedication
and so that's where it started and by
studying all that
it gave me the edge
i really believe when you are a student
of life especially in psychology and
philosophy
you get the edge because when people are
having problems you can see perspective
around it
and once you have perspective you got
superpowers
because most people are trapped in their
problems
and if you have perspective how people
have solved or managed these things in
the past
you have superpowers to people they
can't believe like how did you know to
say that or that i'm like oh i read that
in a personal violin book 10 years ago
and that made the big difference for me
wow
i'm extremely grateful for
the
patience and love of my family
in this particular project it took me
away more than anything else
uh i'm actually really grateful that
i've gotten to know you better
and getting this to be the first like
in-depth conversation with it yeah it's
fun because i think that you're very
talented at holding a space for people
your team too
about holding a space for people just be
like
this is me this is what i you know about
yeah um
and then i would also
you know i'm always grateful for the god
for the second chance i got
from the standing on the car like i got
it like
knowing that each day you get up
and you it's not
you know self-help
psychobabble it's like
knowing that life is limited and you get
a second chance every morning of like
showing the world more of who you are
you know breathing
taking that walk with your love
just having that every day kind of a new
beginning
i feel that in my career i'm sharing
that with you now and by the time this
comes out you know i'll have a new show
out the brendan show
i've never done that before that's a new
opportunity i'm grateful for the new
opportunities i think right now you and
i have the ability to share our messages
farther and wider than we've ever had
before i'm super grateful that we're
alive like right now at this time on the
planet when i think
our messages really need to be heard
when we're you know surrounded sometimes
by a cultural society politics is so
negative
to to to have a platform to share
something good right now i'm so grateful
for that number one issue with being
productive isn't that you people usually
don't know what to do with the day it's
that they look at it with dread and they
accept that feeling and they stop
like i don't wanna so they stop
even though
even though if they looked past the
immediate dreadful activity and looked
into the future about the benefits it
would give them
if they could reconnect with that they
could push through
it's that when we get in the short term
just automatic feelings automatic
emotions that come up those things when
they're not monitored consciously
and sometimes they're not overridden
by a higher calling a higher ambition a
higher ambition to serve a higher
mission
then what ends up happening is we go ah
i'll do it tomorrow
i'll skip this one and you know i'll get
the workout in tomorrow and then workout
comes tomorrow i'll get it in next
friday and then it doesn't come in next
friday and then
i'll get the work in the work doesn't
happen and we keep telling ourselves
these stories i'll do it when i feel
like it
but i hope if one thing you've learned
here is the power plant doesn't have
energy it
you need to generate the energy in which
you need to excel and serve in this
world number one
[Music]
is my friend hat which is so important
uh this is
where when i'm having a bad day i always
say okay
[Music]
if i was coaching my absolute dearest
best friend in the world who just went
through the same day
what would i suggest that they do
next
not how would i change their life not
some big high flu and stuff like what
would i suggest that person they do like
literally next
in that situation they're in would it be
you know what you really need to call
your mom you know what you you need to
call that person apologize you know what
you need to send that email you know
what you need to do is take this but
what would i tell my absolute best most
adored friend to do as their very next
step not the whole plan just what's one
thing i would tell my absolute best
dearest friend
i ask myself this question
probably two three times a week
right because i'll get frustrated by
something something will piss me off or
i'll be bummed that something crashed
and burned i'll be like okay
would i if my best friend just went
through that exact same thing what would
i say they should do
first and of course once i think of what
they should do first then the next step
comes and the next step in the next step
meaning
kind of coach and advise yourself from a
third party standpoint i know you
probably know you should do that but
here's the way that i make it stick
i write
the letter
this means i sit down with a blank piece
of paper and i write the letter to
myself from the best friend's
perspective dear brendan you're really
ugly and stupid but you're my best
friend so buddy here's what i recommend
you do
about the situation that you're in
here's how i think you should think
about it here's what i recommend that
you should do
and i literally write the letter
to myself from the perspective of my
best friend does that make sense that's
what i call putting on my friend hat and
i write the letter dear brendan
and sometimes it's just i write it it's
super short it's on a little note card i
write like 10 sentences other times man
i gotta dig deep and that thing becomes
like a four-page letter to myself you
know and we know
from psychology is specifically dealing
with therapy and trauma
that if you will write yourself a letter
it does significantly change your
emotional well-being
and writing it from this perspective
as a friend has i have found made my
letters much more compassionate much
more thoughtful much more positive so i
just put my friend head on i write
myself a little letter that's number one
if you're angry all the time you got to
change how you look at the world
yes there's a lot in the news that can
piss you off yes there's a lot going on
that causes outrage all day long on
twitter or social media somewhere but if
that's your sole focus no wonder you're
upset all the time lots of people are
angry right now because of the news or
something chaotic or terrible or
something they don't agree with is
happening in the world but that's not
new
there's always chaos there's always
turmoil there's always bad things happen
in the world but if that's your focus no
wonder you're having that anxiety and
that frustration and that anger all the
time you got to change both your focus
and how you're reacting to things when
you do see it so first let's work on
your focus you know are as much as
you're angry all the time are you also
noticing the beauty of this world
i mean the odds that you're even alive
and having your breath is something to
connect to every single morning to have
reverence for your life in the morning
to wake up you know one of my late
mentors was wayne dyer an amazing
amazing teacher and he always talked
about how he woke up he rolled over he
put his feet on the ground he said
thank you
thank you
thank you
he was grateful for his day and he began
that way and i think so many people
right now they kind of roll up in bed
and
they grab their freaking phone and they
start going through the news and social
media and what are they cueing
immediately i'm cueing stress chaos
turmoil clickables you know it's like
click make click click clickbait no
wonder you're frustrated you're
activating your brain immediately right
off the beginning of the day in all the
turmoil of the world put the dang phone
down get up and think about what you're
grateful for about what you want to
achieve and give and serve and create
that day about who needs you to be on
your a-game that day so you can focus on
that instead of like this in bed that
will change how you start your day and
then listen a lot of people who are
angry all the time they're also in
outrage all the time because they're
focusing on the problem all the time and
they're bemoaning the problem they're
calling out the problem complaining
about the problem judging criticizing
getting upset all the time a ton of
people who stay in anger all the time
are failing to be
solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem problem
problem outrage hours outrage but listen
when you become a solution based person
you say okay i actually want to do
something about this problem and you
start taking positive steps to at least
address it or to participate suddenly
that anger goes into a new fire and that
fire is called enthusiasm it is easy to
switch anger into enthusiasm when you
become solution based as a mindset when
you say okay i don't like this let me do
something let me let me call somebody
let me take this action let me write
that letter let me send that email let
me get my friends together let's go
protest let's go get involved let's
participate because participation
turns anger often into enthusiasm people
say brendan i'm scared to start my dream
i'm like you're not scared to start your
dream you're embarrassed to be seen
starting small
big difference it's not about the dream
that's freaking you out it's about how
you're gonna feel
chasing the dream it's about how you're
gonna be perceived chasing the dream
it's about how you fear at night it
won't turn out the way you wanted it's
not about the dream it's about how
you're processing how it will feel
chasing
the dream and once you figure that out
you see that you can rewire yourself you
can teach yourself to think differently
about the journey and the process
because look you know no matter how
small you start
start something that matters
start something that brings your life
back you know start something that makes
your heart feel full start something
that does scare you allow that fear
allow that worry allow that anxiety a
little bit because that's just saying
you're growing you're learning you're
changing you're getting going but let's
be very clear most people what they're
really scared about is being embarrassed
well i don't know if i quit my job and i
start this thing what do my co-workers
think when i do that i don't know if i
start this what are my friends going to
say when they see me playing small and
not doing big things because every big
project starts with small little tasks
that don't look sexy oh what's what's
everyone think about me that i chose
this route when the other thing was over
here and that was a better choice what
people are scared about is being
rejected or more being embarrassed
i tell people all the time don't be
embarrassed to start small i i think
about when i started doing videos you
know it wasn't we're 200 million video
views now we i mean tell you what when i
started i was okay with the fact that it
was like 10 people watched my videos you
know nine of them was my mom on
different browsers probably hitting
refresh to make me feel better about
myself you know like i accepted the fact
that starting small was part of the game
instead of bemoaning that i honored that
process i said that is part of it being
small in a big pond with big fish is
part of the game and only until you keep
playing keep moving keep building do you
ever become one of the big fish
you have to be okay with being small and
so if you start your channel or you
start your thing and only 100 people
watch it hey that's a hundred people
who heard your message that's a hundred
people who you help that's a hundred
people who you change your mindset for
that's a hundred people who let you do
your own thing and watch and even if
they were haters at least you started
penetrating their mind
get in the game never be embarrassed
about starting small or scrappy or
crappy because that's part of the
journey it's supposed to be that way so
don't fear it acknowledge that's part of
it i'm gonna honor that let's go i was a
maybe 24 25 year old man and i was a
member of kiwanis and if you guys didn't
know kiwanis was is a it's kind of like
rotary or lions club um it's uh it's a
a
it's a nonprofit organization that's
dedicated towards service in in the
community and i was in kiwanis and i was
the youngest one hands down like in in
the room we get together every single
month on a tuesday and we have lunch and
we'd have a speaker in and then we'd
talk about a volunteer project we were
going to do that month and that was kind
of how it went in kiwanis for me and so
i but in my room
i was 24 25 in the room every tuesday
when we got together
everyone else was older i mean they were
like
50s and 60s and 70s older when i was 20
i was the youngest person in the room
every single time
and
i remember i was having a particularly
challenging time because i was thinking
about quitting my job but i was scared
because i didn't i hadn't saved any
money
um
i didn't know exactly what i wanted to
do i just knew that i i knew that the
job wasn't the thing at the time
but i didn't know what it was and so i
was scared to make the leap and i was
just i was kind of struggling with some
existential stuff because you know it'd
been four or five years i hadn't had a
girlfriend
and it was just frustrating i was like
dating but i wasn't able i just wasn't
making real connections on when i was
dating and i was just unhappy in that
part of my life i didn't know what i was
doing my career i didn't have a
significant relationship i was like oh
man
i'm just kind of i didn't feel good
and so i was having a really down day
on that particular tuesday and i went in
and i was sitting next to this guy and
he was one of the just one of the
awesome kawanians that who was there and
he was um i think he was probably 59 60
years old he was in banking um very
successful wealthy guy happy hap just he
was like a happy-go-lucky grandpa type
you know just a good dude and i'm just
kind of listing off to him all these
things that suck
you know
and he says what are you doing about it
and i said well you know i
you know and he says well i bet and he
said i bet i know what's going on he's
you're going home you're probably
watching too much tv drinking too much
beer and
sitting alone too often or you're going
out and not having any fun and
we're just talking my mode was yeah i
kind of i go inside so i kind of pull
away from people when i'm unhappy
and so i was like yeah i kind of pull
away and i'm in my house and he says why
i know how to solve your problem
i said oh what is it he goes buy tickets
like buy ticket when you buy tickets he
goes i want you to open up the paper
remember the papers says i want you to
open up the paper and he goes i want you
to see what's going on in your town
and i want you to buy tickets to
whatever's coming up the next seven
weekends
is it is there a symphony coming to town
buy tickets is there a ballet buy
tickets is there a uh an art museum buy
tickets is there he said is there a
concert buy tickets
and i said what do you mean i just buy
tickets i want you buy one two three
four tickets and i want you to take your
friends and i just want you to go i want
you to buy tickets and i want you to go
and i'm like what the hell does this
have to do with anything i'm even
talking about he goes just buy the
tickets and come back next month tell me
about the tickets and i'm like no and he
literally pulls out his wallet and i'll
never forget he sets down three 100
bills
and he goes
buy the tickets here's the money and i'm
like what are you even i was literally
so frustrated it's a long story short
i'll try to keep it shorter
but so i bought tickets i got like a
symphony ticket i uh got a there was
like a dance troupe in town or something
weird there's a dave matthews concert
and what else there's one other thing i
can't remember what it was uh shoot
there's something about the tickets i
went with one or two or three friends
and
went to them and the second i remember
even i remember the opening act for the
dave matthews band started and i was
like
got it
got it
because sometimes when you're down and
out
you got to get out and about
and so
i was down and out and he got me out and
about and then with you with your
friends and you're socializing and it's
in a new environment and things are
happening and my mind just started
turning on again i started getting all
these ideas and these dreams that i
don't know where they were they weren't
in my room they weren't in my bed these
ideas and dreams they weren't happening
in my journal the the the ideas and
dreams they weren't happening in my my
daily planner it was like i was stuck
there so he moved me over here have you
ever been
like at a ballet or a symphony in
orchestra and you're just sitting there
and all of a sudden
you feel amazing
like the music hits you this idea comes
in and you walk out and you feel amazing
have you ever gone to a broadway show
you went in and you were frustrated and
freaked out because all the horrible new
york traffic and all of a sudden you
laugh your ass off and you leave the
broadway show and you feel like a
million dollars and now
no problem is going to slow you down
that's buy tickets
buy tickets to seminar buy tickets to
the event buy tickets the art museum the
ballet buy tickets and i mean if you're
down and out and your life sucks right
now go buy tickets for the next four
weeks and i promise you'll be like damn
buy tickets that changed my life
changed my life too and i've learned
ever since then like if i'm down and out
it's like buy tickets what if your
parents don't support you who cares if
your team doesn't support you who cares
if your friends think you're crazy who
cares if nobody in this world sees your
dream it is not your parents or your
professors or your peers or the world's
job to support your dream that's your
dream that dream was sewed into your
heart that dream was given to you to
nurture to protect to fulfill it's not
somebody else's job so if your parents
don't like your idea
you don't have to live your life to
please just your parents if your friends
think you're crazy it's not your job to
make all your friends think that you're
sane if your professors or the people in
your community think oh my gosh you're
just reckless and crazy and stupid
it's not your job to prove that you're
smart to them your job is to fulfill
that heart's desire your job is to
fulfill that part of you that is begging
you and pleading you to follow your
dreams to follow your heart to create
your thing so first and foremost don't
think that is everybody else's job to
support you it's not everybody else's
job to cheer you on to give you money to
invest in you to patch you on the back
every time you walk into your house at
night and you did a good job
it's okay that other people have a
different vision for themselves than you
do just like you don't need to judge
other people because you don't like
their dreams their desires or the way
they live their life or do their nine to
five
then you shouldn't worry if they judge
yours and that's the first thing i
always tell people is it is not other
people's responsibilities to support you
or to believe in you and i know that you
know when i wrote my first book
no one believed me i quit my nine to
five job and everyone goes you're so
crazy to quit this job
who are you to be a writer you're a dumb
kid it's true who was i to be a writer
but i didn't worry what other people
thought or if their judgment was
approval for me to go ahead
in my heart i knew i wanted to write i
wanted to create and that desire was
what i listened to
not other people's judgments or opinions
and remember most other people's
opinions are completely uninformed
opinions about you so i say first and
foremost own your dream it's yours your
job to cultivate it's okay if nobody
else believes you you got to let go of
those things that upset you three years
ago five years ago 10 years ago if
you're an adult and you're still angry
and pissed about things that happen to
you in high school
you need a therapist and i say that with
all sincerity and all respect
if you're having mental thoughts that
are coming from a place that are
literally based 5 10 20 years ago that
you just didn't deal with yet you need
help dealing with it and you need to get
yourself a meditation practice or a
therapist or in some kind of way that
you're on a consistent basis letting
things go here's what i do every sunday
i go okay what was i pissed about this
last week what really bothered me okay i
gotta let that go
because you can't keep charging into the
next week angry from last week you gotta
let it go you gotta find a clean slate
for yourself so that you could your soul
can expand and can be positive and can
be ambitious and motivated and serving
the next week because listen anger after
anger after anger hatred after hatred
after hatred criticism after criticism
after criticism rejection after
rejection after rejection outrage after
outrage after outrage it weighs you
down so you've got to change how much of
that you're taking in and you've got to
make sure every single week you're doing
some kind of like mental detox to let
that stuff go and instead of cultivating
the anger cultivate the gratitude
cultivate the enthusiasm and you can
change your life people always say well
brandon i lost my motivation i'm like
you didn't lose your motivation you
forgot to show up in the morning look
and think and feel what is it you are
fighting for see you just show up and
sometimes you check your inbox and you
look on social media or you listen that
podcast or even you do your workout but
you're not thinking and obsessing what
is it i'm fighting for in my life right
now or who is it i am fighting for
because if you begin your day grounded
in what you find to be purposeful
meaningful important fulfilling
and you say what is that i'm fighting
for why am i showing up why is it
necessary that i deliver with excellence
today and you really emotionally get
connected to something that's the
challenge people are losing their
motivation because they're not
emotionally connected to anything
outside of like the outrage on social
media outside of the outrage of the news
they're losing that fire inside that
wants to build something create
something deliver something
overcome something
so now they're just focused on everybody
else and the real thing is they didn't
lose their motivation they got
distracted two different things right if
you're really connected with what you
are doing and why you were doing it and
who you are doing for specifically
everything changes and you'll overcome
even the distractions as i've written
six books now i have been surrounded by
so many critics and so many judgments
you know we have 200 million video views
of my
views on my videos online guess what a
lot of the people were haters
but instead of seeing them and getting
angry about it i just see it and it's
like swipe
it doesn't affect me anymore part of
maturity is getting that point where you
can see criticism and see hatred
and not make it your own
not make it about your identity to allow
other people's opinions and judgments to
live out there because they're not going
to go away you need to accept that the
criticisms the judgments the hatred it's
not going away you'll probably only hear
more of it as you grow even as you get
more fame or more people liking you or
more people accepting you or you get
promoted
people ultimately will support you as
you get momentum but people will still
hate you so if you don't deal with it
now if you don't make a switch in your
mind that says ah either i'm gonna limit
my exposure to them or i'm gonna change
how my i react to them you will always
be slave to other people's opinions and
that is not a life of freedom that you
want to live
the reason people are scared to start
their dream is because they're seeing
this big complex thing
that i mean they're looking out and it's
this huge thing they see the complexity
of the final vision of the dream and so
starting
now is too overwhelming they're not
scared to start
the dream they're scared of the feeling
of feeling overwhelmed that's what
they're scared of so how do you deal
with that stop thinking you have to have
everything perfect and complete at the
beginning
the finish line is 26 miles ahead what
matters now is step one two three four
the first mile you need to figure out
what is the first mile towards your
dream not what's the finish line look
like of course if you look at the finish
line it's intimidating you look at
somebody who already has the business
you want you look at somebody who
already has the car and the dream the
house and the perfect life and they've
done it all already they're 5 10 15 20
years in front of you and it seems so
complex why should i even start look how
far ahead they are they had more miles
they put more miles in but you can't
compete with their miles you got to
start with your first step right here
right now you go okay i'm going to be
okay starting small and instead of
trying to in day one have it all
complete and take on all the complexity
i'm gonna do one thing here three goals
today three goals the next day three
goals the next day and i'm gonna get
that momentum going because with that
momentum comes more motivation with that
momentum more learning with that
momentum more progress but it only
begins if you're okay
starting small
and taking on little bites at your dream
and not trying to eat the whole thing
all at once because it will overwhelm
you we completed the world's largest
study of high performers worldwide with
data points of over 2 million people
from 190 countries around the world and
when we pulled then we found out who
those high performers were the people
who had the longest term success
there was no
question at all
that they tend to be focusing on
one person or maybe their team
or maybe their financial situation they
were focused on like one or two things
for the reason that they were doing
things and it wasn't like i'm gonna
change the world and they had some big
you know esoteric dreamy kind of thing
they're like you know what i gotta make
the rent you know what i gotta buy this
new thing you know what i wanna build
this team you know what i wanna build
this business you know what i gotta get
my art out here i'm fighting for that
but they were fighting for one
specific thing maybe two but it was so
specific
for me it would be live love matter and
it'd be something around those truths
because at the end of your life what i
found
uh you know
it's hard to give perspective this but
for 20 years i've been telling people to
find those questions
and no matter what and i don't know if
you know this but i volunteered in
hospices for a decade i've been with a
lot of people in their last moments
weeks and months i've been i've been
around a lot of that in my life because
i wanted to see if
what i experienced on that car was what
other people experienced in some ways it
was
in some ways at the end we all wanted to
know did i live and how that was and did
i love and i matter luckily i just knew
that psychologically with familiarity
you know the odds of decreasing anxiety
is extremely high so it's basically like
running a simulation run that simulation
exactly like a pilot running that
simulation over and over and over if
you're a pilot and you run the
simulation that crashes 50 times the
first 10 you're mortified
the last
you know 12 you're on the dials
you know and so i think just running the
pattern over and over visually is really
powerful
the world completely underestimates the
power of visualization
completely
uh misutilizes the human power of
contemplation
uh
you know the number one thing i say to
my high performance clients is going
through the motions is the death of high
performance
high performers don't go through the
motions yeah i think they're
contemplative they're intentional
they're thoughtful they practice they
they want it to go well
and the reason most people don't do that
is because the pressure it puts a lot of
pressure on yourself
but that's what makes people great truth
is
life will never
be
joyous unless you bring the joy
i really feel like that so many people
are waiting to have happiness and
they're just they're waiting to like
well maybe when my boss loosens up i'll
loosen up or you know
when when when she's vulnerable i'll be
vulnerable or it's like we're waiting
for something i'm like it's not your
life will never be what it
is going to be
unless you bring that thing
you know for me i wanted to be
i want to be more bold in my life
that was one of my goals because i
wasn't that you know i wasn't that guy
who would just like go out and do the
things i do now so i made gold like i
was like bold is an intention i set it
as an alarm on my phone
everything my alarm would go off three
times a day and bold would pop up and i
conditioned myself over seven years to
be more bold which is a big deal for me
um
and
because i wanted i wanted that i had to
learn how to bring that so whatever you
want life you got to bring it camera was
super awkward for me
and i was like okay but if i want to
change the world guess what is necessary
communication skills i'm going to have
to learn that i i was not i didn't
wasn't raised in a place i was raised in
montana where men
didn't really communicate
except with looks glances and fists you
know so it's like if a guy lifted it
wasn't like we like we're gesturing
right yeah where i'm from if their hand
came up you're getting punched in the
face man that was it
so i had to learn emotional intelligence
that's a skill
uh so communication emotional
intelligence when i got into our
business i had to learn copywriting i
know what that was email marketing i
didn't know i had to learn coding i
don't none of that i knew what it was
but i was always confident and i think
real confidence is your belief
in your ability to figure things out
i believe in my ability to figure things
out give me enough time energy resources
study books mentors i will figure out
hey you want me to go to the moon i'll
figure it out even though i have no idea
today i can learn and get mentors so
that's a deep part of my life high
performers have that they just believe
they'll figure things out that
confidence is what ties a lot of their
habits and their abilities together we
all have to have those things in our
business or our brands or the things
that we're being productive towards that
push us that challenge us if you don't
have three or four of those each year
that are your form of business or
productivity marathons
build them back in
build in challenging expressions
for yourself
each year build them in we all need our
own marathon each year whether that's a
true running marathon or for me this is
it for me
and i got eight of these a year
that i build in that make me sharp i
don't need to do them the better use of
my time would just be doing more videos
on the internets
more social media but this
this pushes me this demands excellence
from me community having people in my
life who i can you know when i'm on
the road for x amount of time or i'm
dealing with a super hard client or
we're rolling out a leadership program
to a fortune 50 company or you know i'm
doing my first you know major deal with
oprah winfrey network and i don't know
what to do i am so incredibly fast
of asking people what to do
i'm also incredibly fast in sharing how
i feel about it
being like oh you know i feel really
awkward about this
uh you know i'm unsure you know i'm
having a lot of self-doubt how would you
deal with it like i'm somebody who
expresses his emotions all the time my
frigging tag line is bring the joy like
everybody knows that why because i want
to make sure people know you're we're
going to create this energy because
emotion is not something you have it is
something you generate
emotion can be an impulse
but feelings
is our interpretations of those impulse
over a period of time and i said i want
to feel vibrancy joy love connection
satisfaction fulfillment in my life
so i'm going to learn to generate those
emotions how do you learn to generate
the emotions
you read psychology how do you learn to
generate the emotions you try like
you're just like i i'm gonna go we're
gonna have date night tonight i'm gonna
make it a fun night
i'm gonna make it a fun night i'm gonna
i'm gonna do things to see can i make
people laugh can i make people turn
their lights on um you learn to
control your own emotions
and or deal with them in better ways as
you decide to be a more mature person i
think
the challenge
you have when you're good
is that you're good yeah so like i'm
doing pretty good already yeah it's easy
the better you get the more expertise
development you get the easier it is to
show up and go through the motions yeah
you don't have to prepare as much you
don't have to practice as much you just
yeah good results whatever you can do is
good enough yeah but what happens when i
perform it eats at them
because they know they got more in the
tank
and they're like you know what that was
good but i could have gotten another and
it's not that they're dissatisfied we
take on that myth in this book high
performers are not dissatisfied so
people who say never be satisfied
they got to look at why they're saying
that because
it's not true because high performers
are satisfied they're they're striving
satisfied doesn't mean they're not
striving for the next big thing want to
become better but they're happy
hyperwarmers are happier than all of
their peers i mean by significant almost
double digits so it's really significant
um but i think for me
i need to constantly be reminding myself
like okay
what is the reason you need to perform
really well right now
and i need to be more consistent about
that question
um so i set up triggers in my life to do
that you know um
from every time i stand in line
i have a line trigger door triggers i
have phone triggers
you know so when i stand in line i
always say what level am i right now
in terms of my presence and energy
skill 110. one i suck i'm dead i'm not
even alive not even feeling grateful you
know ten i'm like i'm vibrant i'm joyous
here i am um and i i rate myself
consistently on that and it just
retouches me like the knee i i want to
feel it's necessary to be grateful
i want to feel it's necessary to be
great i want to feel it's necessary to
do my best but you don't get that
without reminders so you got a set of
alarms or triggers or some you know no
cards around that whatever it is it
takes for you to have that but i know
for me
raise after the research
i didn't get how
i mean
i mean you're talking from every athlete
to every high ceo this is what they did
there
and i didn't find this you'll see all
the questions i asked them in the book i
really had to dial in their psyche
and when we found that i was like is
that a thing
that they'd really that's i mean but
they all do and so it inspired me to
level them like i'm going to raise my
necessity and i'll i'm going to practice
everything in the book to get that up a
little higher i would say maybe not the
most popular answer i go to the fear
how are you going to look
silly or stupid
you're not going to ask questions
and you're going to end up in the wrong
place and people are like why don't you
just ask
like follow the fear if the fear says
i'm scared i'm looking stupid by asking
questions like well let's flip that
because if you don't ask questions
you're definitely going to look stupid
you're definitely going to end up in the
wrong place yeah you're definitely i
mean you're you're manifesting the very
thing you fear by not doing the thing
that you're scared and being
you know you don't want to be vulnerable
about yeah i think those who learn to
endure
hardship struggle challenge difficulty
pain grief vulnerability failure um
regret
that's one side of that coin
if you learn to do that but you also
know on the other side
learn to allow
joy fulfillment satisfaction a sense of
hold up hold on i have to stop you allow
is that the word you want to commit to
you said bring i'm going to build okay
build it
you have to first allow it because what
most people do is
if on the other side of the coin it's
super etched in
what happens is even when that impulse
comes up i like this oh no i'm not
supposed to like this so you have a lot
of people who are extremely talented
at the top levels who they do endure the
pain and they really like the pain and
they will allow that all the day long
they'll allow that now because they'll
tell their brain
this is what's expected
but they also don't let themselves feel
good
when feeling good is there
this is a real big problem i mean if you
study like psychosis a lot of people who
really struggle with addictions
um eating disorders are super common who
even when they feel that sense of
self-love or self accept oh i'm not
supposed to feel that no you really
there is an element
to personal development where you have
to allow the good feelings and not push
them away because it's like i should i
don't deserve to feel that because a
huge part of the world is telling
themselves i don't yet deserve to feel
happy
even though happiness comes up i
shouldn't feel that yet i'm going to
keep striving it's not until i get the
next two million then i'll let myself
feel happy even though they had that
good monday and so you have a lot of
people who are striving in difficulty
who also have not taught themselves the
emotional side
of what is called
the most important movement in the
history of the world in psychology
called positive psychology kicked off by
marty seligman a good friend of mine
michelle just sent me high without that
work of saying no no we also have to
allow ourselves
and teach ourselves to flourish feel
satisfaction feel joy so i'm 100 with
you and i'm like the rule is that's one
side of the coin
and the other rule is
make sure you teach yourself
to generate the positive emotions
because what happens is if you don't
teach yourself to generate the positive
emotions as well
then what ends up happening is you burn
out or
you become a cliche of the person who
had it all
and never felt fulfilled think of your
life
as being a productively fulfilling life
that productivity is not a time
management thing
it's a purpose thing
i don't think of time management when i
think of productivity i think of purpose
i think of who do i want to be what do i
want to contribute
what will be fulfilling for me
because if you don't have
something bigger than just
blocks of time which are important
but there's not something that we
together are going towards
where it's this set of dreams
where
there's personal meaning and there is
social contribution
we won't go
let go
of the baggage
you're never going to touch the full rim
of your potential if you're weighted
down by baggage from your elementary
school years your high school years your
college years these last four years
listen the last chapters of the book
you've gone through them you finished
them you flipped the page you got a new
chapter here
and you have to be willing to break from
the past to have the future you so
desperately desire
you have to have the courage
to allow yourself
to honor the past as it was
to forgive those who need to be forgiven
to forgive yourself
and to acknowledge that everything led
you to this point now everything
those crappy times those times when
you're depressed those times when you
gave up on yourself those times when
someone else gave up on you those times
that you gave up on others
the times that you quit the times that
you failed the times that you felt so
small you were embarrassed
those times don't live in this moment
and the more of those times that you
cultivate in your mind and you ruminate
on and you think and you self-talk on
and you revisit in your mind the more
disempowering times from the past
hurtful
times from the past
failures from the past that you keep
running in your head
what that is doing is that is taking up
the very free space necessary for the
bold ideas to come in
it's taking up the space for the very
needed white space for creativity to
come in
for the dreams to come in for the best
you to speak through from
like
it's hard
for you to live an authentic and true
and vulnerable and real life if you're
always speaking through your baggage
if you're always thinking through
your baggage and you guys know what i'm
talking like everyone's got different
baggage maybe your
maybe your baggage is your divorce
or that last job they are not relevant
today
and the only reason they're relevant
today is if either you allow them to be
relevant from those situations or this
person's revisiting you or you're
running the same old story
you're running the same old excuses yeah
i can't do this because i suck at
relationships no you sucked your
relationships 10 years ago well i can't
do this because you know uh i i failed
yeah six months ago today's a new day
homie like
you gotta access this day dude
this day
is fresh
this day is clean
this day woke up showered
ready
prepped for you by the universe or
spirit or god or luck or cosmos whatever
you want to call it this day
says to you when you wake up in the
morning the day whispers to you do not
fear me for i have been brought here for
you
you don't fear the day
that day has been brought here for you
you never know a person if you don't
know their goals
and if you don't know their goals you're
never going to be a great friend
you'll never be their great lover their
great supporter their great family
member
and it's weird though because most
people actually don't know other
people's goals i'll ask family members
to say what what's your sister's
goals you know she wants to be a dancer
okay what kind of dancer when
what does she want to do with that
career is the short term is a long term
like you have to really get into
people's goals to understand their heart
and so that's what i want you to do is
if you want to be a great spouse to
somebody you got to re-engage and say
hey what do you want at this stage of
your life because i know i know what you
used to want then we had kids but where
are you at now
and you got to get that conversation
with your partner and say hey listen i
know we've been through a couple of
weird months where we just haven't
really felt each other out it's like
let's just do some personal development
like what do you really want to do right
now at this stage of your life because
you have to understand when i say this
stage of your life that's very specific
meaning a lot of people's goals change
and it changes like every three months
every year every three years so if you
haven't had the conversation with the
important people in your life recently
about what your goals are and about what
their goals are then i'm telling you
you're just skimming at the surface
because if you don't support other
people's dreams how can you ever have a
deep relationship with them and if you
don't share your dreams and your heart
and your desire with other people how
can they possibly help you meet that
hunger how can they possibly help you
become the best version of you if you
haven't shared it so you also have to be
very honest with what's your real
thoughts what's your real feelings
what's your real dreams what do you
really want at this stage of your life
with all the important people around you
it's one of my favorite things with high
performers to say okay do all the people
around you know what you really want
right now are they clear on what your
goals are are are they clear about how
they can support that or how much you
want them to be involved in it it's like
a lot of people start their own business
but they don't tell the other people
around them what that business is what
it requires how they love their support
and so we all go it alone
and isn't going it alone the opposite of
having healthy supportive relationships
so first thing you got to do if you want
better relationships get to know other
people's goals many of you you've been
waiting to hire that first virtual
assistant
or that person to help you at the house
so you can focus on your business who
can support you with the kids or
somebody who can you know come in and
help just clean the house some of you
waiting to hire that manager that ceo
that ceo and i'm here to tell you do it
like set your quarter one goals of 2019
to hire the team that you need don't
finish quarter one without the team that
you need in place trained and going for
some of you that might be a hundred
employees some of you that's ten i don't
know what your situation is but i'm here
to tell you higher sooner higher better
if you want to deal with self-doubt you
absolutely must start entering each day
as more intentional of a human because
the issue is one of the reasons we doubt
ourselves is because we're just all over
the place you know sometimes you're cool
in this situation but you're dumb in
that situation sometimes you don't do
well here but you do well here and what
happens is so many people they're going
through the motions or they're just
showing up in life every single day and
they're reacting
and because they're always reacting
they don't have a character
they haven't determined who am i really
who am i going to act like in this
situation who i'm going to behave like
in this situation how i'm going to treat
people in this situation because they
haven't shown up intentional enough and
sought to live out that intention
they feel a lot of discord in life like
they don't know who they are because
they just keep showing up and reacting
to what's there but guess what what's
there is always different the world is
always changing people are always
changing situations are always changing
so if all you're ever doing is showing
up and reacting i guess i'll just go
through it and see how it goes you're
never forming an intentional character
so of course you doubt yourself because
every situation is different and you can
never have certainty in that but you can
have strength inside if from now on you
wake up every day and you say okay i'm
gonna be these three words today and you
just set the words you say okay i'm
gonna be fun i'm gonna be playful and be
kind and that day you are fun playful
and kind and the next day you say okay
i'm being patient today i'm going to be
thoughtful and i'm going to be
appreciative and you're patient
thoughtful and appreciative you do that
over and over and over again set an
intention for who to be
be that set an intention be that set an
intention be that and you do that in
more situations in your life and more
days and more weeks and more months and
more years and one day you wake up and
you like you're confident in self
because you know that you can direct
your mind and your emotions and your
body to be the person who you really
want to be
the more often you do that the more real
genuine self-confidence will come into
your life the most important thing i
know this sounds so so silly but common
sense is not always common practice and
that's why so many potentially great
people fail to ever achieve their
potential and that's this
listen
you have to get your visualization game
down
visualization that means listen when i
wake up when i got a dream
i wake up in the morning before i get
out of bed i close my eyes i just see it
happening a little bit and i'll lay in
bed and let my mind and my body stir up
a little bit of excitement or sometimes
even anxiety about seeing the actual
thing that i want happen
that was for me at one part of my life
seeing myself on stages speaking and
training to people one part of my life
it was seeing my book come out and
seeing it on the new york times
bestseller list or seeing it on the
amazon bestseller list it was sometimes
seeing myself coaching major celebrities
or sitting side by side with an oprah
winfrey or tony robbins or larry king
all of which i've been able to do it was
because i visualized what i really
wanted but here's the thing it's not
just visualization that's like
the first part it's also affect
we talk about high performance and in
psychology about this thing called
affect which is basically feelings and
emotions i i want you to allow yourself
to literally not just kind of casually
see it like put yourself there and feel
it and sense it and see and feel it and
drink it in like really take in the
ambiance the circumstances like really
visualize and feel
what you are seeing
that's so key i mean as silly as this is
i literally would lay there and i'm like
okay if i'm going to feel like
feel like fill out the ideal
thing what what questions would i ask to
really get going i just start literally
seeing myself at my desk in the morning
feeling filling out the high performance
planner
thinking about other people worldwide
filling out at the same time as me
and
knowing that i got this tribe of people
on this path
of trying to be their best with me and
imagining people coming up and says oh
my gosh bro you know brandon you
completely changed my morning you
completely changed my weekly routine you
completely changed my life because i
never tracked my habits before i never
assessed my balance every single week
between family friends work finances
adventure learning etc
everything every tool that we put in
here i could just imagine someone saying
brandon i really appreciate that part
and i literally just thought about it
because i wanted it to feel like you
know i was excited for the project
otherwise what look how easy it is to
diminish anything in our lives well it's
just a book it's just a planner it's
just a it's just a video it's just a
cosmetic line it's just a beauty thing
it's just that like we all diminish our
dreams we make excuses and we make our
dreams like ah we throw it away because
we're scared to feel it you know what
i'm saying
it's easier to throw it away that's no
big deal avoid it not no problem
and we mess up
i want you to feel it stop detaching
from your dreams
stop avoiding that anxious scary feeling
of thinking how hard it's going to be
and thinking how great it's going to be
because most people just they don't even
think about it because it causes too
much nerves i'm like dancing those
nerves a little bit let them come up for
you because that's fuel man
that's fuel it's like less brown
toddlers you gotta be hungry you'll
never be hungry if you don't visualize
it see it feel it and want it i've
always really worked extremely hard to
maintain an incredible level of energy
in my mental body my i'm sorry in my you
know mental emotional physical spiritual
being just trying to do everything i can
from the way that i work out to what i
consume to what i don't consume to how i
rest to how i meditate to how i recover
like everything in my life has always
been about how do i bring the joy and if
i'm going to generate the energy i want
to create for you guys how do i do that
specifically
well i've always got these routines and
everything else but what happened this
year i was kind of had my health taken
away a little bit in mid
uh october i got pneumonia
and tonsillitis at the same time
while i was on the road doing multiple
four-day and multiple five-day events
where i'm kind of the lead trainer and
that
kicked my butt and i'm still honestly
recovering from it like i'm i'm still
feeling it i'm still feeling heading
into the final part of this year i'm
still recovering uh don't worry clean
bill of health doctors like you're good
to go they're just your body's may be
recovering and be tired for a while and
i made it 41 42 years without feeling
fatigue outside of times of injury you
know i i
don't think i've ever had the flu i
don't really ever get sick when i get
sick it's like sniffles
but this one was something it just
smacked me i mean i was down and out
it's why i feel like i'm way behind on
my episodes for you all
it's why i feel like we're launching a
few things in january that i'd hope to
launch in you know october so
that like taking care of my health
is always been a priority this year
i learned what it feels like when it's
gone
and many been with me for a long time
that happened in 2011 when i had my
brain injury and i snapped my wrist and
my ribs and my hip um so i'm not
you know
new to pain i'm not new to being sick
but this was the first time where i also
with the sickness
lost motivation
you know where it was like even when i
had like when i was really sick in the
past of my life i would still like wake
up in the day and i'd prime my mind get
excited about what's to come and just go
this year there was about the last two
months i really had to work on that
there were plenty of days i was just
like ugh
not because i didn't love my life or i
wasn't grateful or present you've been
there before like when you just you
physically feel terrible
it is hard to get your mind right a lot
of people have self-doubt in their lives
because they don't have clarity for what
they want
a lot of people wander in a situation
and they have a lot of self-doubt
because they didn't sit down and plan it
out they didn't prepare they didn't ask
mentors or model others or do the
research to figure out okay i should do
a b c d and e in other words if you
don't know the steps to success
of course you'll have more self-doubt
if you don't have the plan if you don't
have the map if you don't know what
you're doing of course you're gonna have
more self-doubt so part of it is just
like
decide to build a plan even if you have
to ask for help and say hey guys how
would you do this what would be your
first step what would be your second
step i'm always asking that even at this
stage of my career i'm still saying hey
guys if you're gonna launch this how
would you do it if you're gonna promote
that how would you do it if you're going
to create this thing how would you do it
if you're going to build this team or
build that business what would you do
and i always try to get the map before i
enter the woods
so that i have the steps i know the path
because if you can remove the doubt
about the path you'll have more
confidence
in yourself i really believe most people
are terrified of embarrassment
they might call it something else
but they're
scared of embarrassment i just put this
video out where it starts for the first
line is you're not scared to start your
dream
you're embarrassed to be seen starting
small
and it just blew up on social media for
us i think i got more direct messages on
that one little post than anything i've
ever done
and uh
people really resonated with it and
because if you think about the truth
about it is that's what it is for a lot
of people they don't
if they quit their job and they go to
start something new they don't want all
their former you know people to see them
doing something that looks the you know
new and fresh and and maybe ugly or not
put together they're scared to be
embarrassed and have other people judge
them
they're scared they might use different
language well you know
you know they might say well i'm just
fearful but if you really dig down the
fearful most people are just scared to
be embarrassed
they're scared to try something and
obviously fail at it
and the perception of that failure
really shuts them down
so
we have to ask different questions and i
ask this all the time i literally use
the word embarrassment i said listen i
i'll say something like
are you not going to try this before we
even get to this like you can see it
you've made it happen are you not going
to try it because you're scared of what
somebody else might think
are you not going to try it because
you're scared of somebody
of what somebody else might think
i ask that all the time
and
almost all the time
people go well you know
i'm not scared but you know i'm worried
what my spouse will think oh i'm not
scared but yeah you know the people at
work might think i'm a little crazy
and i'll explore that with them because
if we can't get them
over that line of embarrassment and the
willingness
for trial and error we won't get them to
do anything
and so my way through embarrassment
for for
me is two different ways just depending
on who the person is when i hear that
someone might be embarrassed to do
something um i'll often start with that
past attempt conversation have you tried
something like this before and people
were horrible to you
and they're always like well no i've
never tried this before oh so you're
making an assumption
that you'd feel uncomfortable
but then i also want to give them
permission of like
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy
and i'll open up that dialogue well yeah
okay well who might think you're crazy
well my spouse is gonna think i'm crazy
cool how are they gonna communicate that
to you well they're gonna call me stupid
have they ever called you stupid before
well no or yes they have i say okay so
you you survived it last time they
called you stupid
would it be worth surviving it again if
they call you stupid if you felt better
because you actually got momentum
towards something that matters to you
like oh
yeah and listen
knowing
that a big frame here and helping people
get over excuses is getting them tied
back to
is what they are after important i
brought that up earlier how important is
this to you do you really want this
well if you said that's important isn't
it worth a little discomfort
haven't you been discomforted before
haven't you felt judged and stupid
before okay so you know you'll survive
that now the question is so the question
is about survival right let's say yeah
it's not about survival great question
is about survival
sounds to me
like the real question
is whether you want it
we know you'll survive
i'm curious
what if we know you'll survive what will
it feel like if you're
thriving would it be worthwhile to have
a few doubters
or look stupid
or be seen as silly
if you woke up
energized by what you were doing honor
the struggle
like so many people bemoan
the hardship
and they hate it and i would say you
know anything you anything you apply
hate to quickly dies you got a dream and
you're hating the process you apply hate
to the process the dream's gonna die you
know it's like don't don't
you know be very be very careful of what
you put hate or things to and most
people do that with hardship and i've
always seen hardships like i'm gonna
honor this process sort of it's a little
samurai mentality you know it's like i'm
gonna honor that this is difficult
because that is precisely what's needed
one hour more per day
on my core three
okay i begin this every year i go okay
first move i know i need to identify
what are the core three things right now
that have been bringing me results this
year
the core three things so as an example
because i'm an entrepreneur like many of
you guys are in my business i go okay
what are the three primary revenue
drivers we have right now
because just like you if you're in
marketing you probably tested a lot of
things throughout the you know the the
early part of the year the spring even
early part of the summer
so my question is what's been working
and i mean
absolutely working what are the three
absolute best things that are working
for you
in your business
or your career or your personal life if
you're not employed or not self-employed
like what's absolutely the three things
that are so working for you
i want you to know what those three
things are
and overall i want you to give an hour
every day more
to a focus of one two or three all three
of those things so let me give an
example right now in in my business
right one of my core three
is our book funnel like so for me as you
guys know as an author and a trainer
when i sell books that's good for the
business we sell books then people want
online courses then they want to come to
our seminars then someday they might
join our program like we're doing here
at our live events or our masterminds or
they might hire us for a coach or they
might hire for me for speaking but the
book is a big core three for the
business right
and so right now i go okay
i need every single day
the rest of this year
to give more time to that thing
every day not on a wednesday not on a
set like every day i need to check in
the numbers create a new ad flip out a
page i need to lead my team better on it
something every day
for that one thing
make sense
so if you got three things what i want i
want an hour
more so that might be in 20 minutes 20
minutes you know and you know 20 minutes
so you're given 20 minutes more each day
or maybe you just choose one
and you're gonna give that an hour more
a day but it's basically this
one more work hour of the day focused on
one of the core three
got it write it down
and this for you
i want you to start this
today
today if that means you're watching this
in munich germany and we finish this
tonight and you stay stay up one more
hour i'm like cheers man do that
but it's like today for those of you who
are here in the u.s in this time zone
i'm like
today
one more hour on focusing i often call
the the core three or the needle movers
the primary three things that are
working i need an hour more from you a
day for the rest of the year
and you will thank me
for the next decade you're like oh my
god brendan
because what happens is and you know
this
you're getting caught up in distraction
and so right now people are lacking
daisical
and they're not focused on the right
things
so i want you to think where are you
distracted i want you to clear out the
distractions i want you to say the core
three things in my business are
and i need you to give an hour or more a
day on those
that's it if you'll start that now
and you'll punch in that hour more
every day until thanksgiving i promise
your christmas will be unbelievable
confidence is your belief in your
ability to figure things out
now often you cheat yourself because you
think well no confidence is i've done
everything i need to do in the world and
i have all the successes and i'm on the
cover of magazines and i'm rich and we
tell ourselves i'll have confidence when
but if you're going to change your life
you need to right now adopt a more
confident mindset and say you know what
confidence i don't have to know
everything in the world i don't want to
be the most successful person on the
block what i need to do is believe in
myself and believe in my ability to
figure things out give me enough time
energy resources mentorship study i can
achieve my dreams that's where it really
begins belief in our ability to figure
things out now of course at a deep
psychological level we know that
confidence is all about your sense of
worth
your sense of capability or ability to
do things
and your belief also
in not only yourself but your future
and let me say those couple things to
you
worth
ability future
if you don't believe you're worth
anything obviously your confidence is
there if you don't believe you're able
to go do anything obviously your
confidence is there psychologists often
call this self-efficacy right you just
don't feel like you can you know be
efficacious or be a person who who gets
things done in the world because you
don't believe in your ability and last
confidence has a lot to do with your
perception of where you'll be in the
future
if you think you're gonna be broke and a
loser in the future obviously you're not
gonna go for it today right if you don't
see if you see yourself as lonely and an
outcast in the future you're obviously
not gonna walk up to her or him and say
hey how are you doing in my industry as
i came in the thought leader industry we
call it which is you know author speaker
coach seminar leader life coach business
coach or online trainer or online
thought leader social media thought
leader in that culture which we just
called the thought leader industry
when i came into it everything was
outsourcing everyone says outsource
outsource outsource don't need to do
video outsource it don't need to do
audio outsource it don't need to learn
how to manage your stage career
outsource it everybody said outsource
everything but i was like you know what
that's just not true
in every given career
there is a set of skills
that you have to master and develop into
if you're going to become excellent at
what you do
if you're ever going to become the
highest paid in your company or highest
paid in your industry or highest paid in
your field
you have to dial it in
and understand what are the skills i'm
working on
you hear me say this before at high
performance academy like if i parachuted
into your house right now or onto your
roof and then climbed down and got in
your house if i came into your house and
i actually looked at your calendar we
opened up your laptop we looked at your
calendar
could i see in your calendar over the
next couple months
clear
block time
that you've designated towards
developing the skills that are necessary
for you to win
like is it in your calendar
or are you just gonna outsource it
and you really have to know what those
skills are you know for what i was doing
people told me at the very beginning my
career brandon you don't need to learn
video
why would you learn video just hire a
videographer or a filmmaker right off
the bat i said well one i just started
my career i'm what you call broke
i don't have the ability to just go hire
people i know some of you guys are
watching this and you're like i don't
have the ability to hire 10 15 20 people
but everyone tells me just go hire
people sometimes you need to develop the
skills to do everything in your business
until you get the amount of revenue
where you know you can hire somebody
and maintain their monthly retainer or
maintain their salary and that was true
for me when i first began people like
just outsource get a videographer i'm
like i don't have the money for that so
i went out and i bought a cheap you know
uh what do they call those things flip
video camera do you remember those
there's a little flip video camera and i
set it up in boxes in my girlfriend's
apartment and i took a little flip video
camera and i didn't know how to use it
so i had to teach myself how to use it
and then i went around i tied it to the
box with duct tape around this box and i
put little notes next to it and i would
have to get up and go press the record
button come back and like hi i ran in
richard and i know i was like freaked
out i didn't know how to do what i was
doing
but i learned how to take that video out
i learned how to upload it i learned how
to edit it i learned how to put in sound
and music and graphics and all these
things it took forever back then and i
had no idea to do it so i would be up
two three four in the morning teaching
myself how to do it
people also said also well brendan just
hire a marketing manager to send your
emails out and build your newsletter
list i was like
i don't have any money to do that
brandon hire somebody to do your online
marketing i was like
i don't know i don't have any money to
do that
but here's the other side of it
it wasn't this i didn't have the money
to do it i also had the foresight to
realize
these were going to be critical skills
to my future
what are the critical skills that would
be necessary for your future
you have to figure that out i didn't
outsource marketing because like if if i
don't learn marketing
see marketing is always going to be a
piece of my future isn't it
so i said i had better learn to master
marketing it's always going to be
something i have to do in my career
what's the skill that you're always
going to have to know and do and i want
you to dive deep in it i want you to
dork out in it why don't you get excited
about it i would spend hours and hours
and hours researching things trying
things learning about things that i had
no skill in
because we live in a world that's
telling this huge lie
and this lie is hey
you know what just follow your passions
just do what you're naturally good at
just follow your strengths
and i'm like well sometimes your
strengths are insufficient
to build the business you need to build
sometimes what you're naturally good at
just because you're good at it and you
like it and you have passion for it
isn't what's required to actually build
and sell and do
i'm not saying don't follow your
strengths i'm saying don't rely on your
strengths
you know the truth is
your mission and your dream
should never be made to bow down to your
limited strengths you want to know how
you become unstoppable
you learn
that the energy you have is not an
accident
and you learn that the energy you have
isn't even the way it works
i always use this metaphor the power
plant doesn't have energy
it generates energy
the power plant doesn't have energy
it generates energy what does that mean
well what a power plant does is it it
draws energy from one resource
and it transforms it to a higher
utilization of energy
and then transmits it to the world
you have that same opportunity you don't
have to wait for happiness to arrive one
day you don't have to wait for good
energy to arrive one day you can
architect that into your mind and into
your body you don't have to hope one day
to feel more joyous you learn to bring
the
joy
you bring the joy you bring the joy to
the morning light you bring the joy to
your family you bring the joy to the
dinner table you bring the joy to that
team who sometimes
and you show up with a positive mindset
every day and they're like who is this
person and you know what when they call
you annoying or they call you
inauthentic or they call tall you too
happy or a stupid optimist or whatever
you take the joy that you're part of a
rare set of human beings who spend their
day like this working on ourselves and
growing because you know what you want
to get believers in your life
get some momentum with a good attitude
and all of a sudden they start coming
around when they're like oh wow you're
different and you're yes i am because
you worked for it because you knew life
was shirt you knew it was short and you
decide at some point in your life hey
there's only so much time let me show up
with greater intention let me deal with
these struggles
just head on you can do this
courageously and you decide to bring the
joy because life is short and like me i
hope you want to
earn
this life you have to have a process
every single week
where you let go of the screw-ups of the
week
see what most people do is they just
carry the screw-ups hate myself failure
screw up
label screw up label screw up label
screw up label and all the mess-ups of
their life
they start defining
as themselves
and the mistake you made weeks ago you
labeled it as part of your identity
versus a behavioral mistake
right behaviors change every day your
behaviors today are different than they
were yesterday like behaviors are very
adaptive and reactionary type of thing
you'll get some behaviors wrong some
behavior is right but what most people
do is they get the wrong behavior
and they pull that wrong behavior and
they pull it into identity
mess up they grab the mess up
and they make it their mindset
no the mess up was a behavioral problem
it is an identity problem and so they
take the mess up the problem and they
make it the personhood
and that's what we call making mountains
out of mo hills
like
so what you got the project in late does
that mean you're a complete failure
no it means you got the project in late
dude next time plan better jesus
right it's like we take it we take the
little things and we blow it up into who
we are
who you are
is not all the mess-ups it's
part of your learning journey but it's
not you
and so you got to know like there's a
difference here
and sometimes baggage is recognizing oh
that was an awkward weird uncomfortable
harmful situation but that's not me
that was a situation it was a behavior
it was something that happened an
occasion
and then we can go okay if that's true
then
who am i really
who do i want to be
who am i now at this age of my life
without those old stories
and you got to give yourself
that distinction but here's the thing i
told you you need a reminder it needs to
be a rhythm for you
it's part of my sunday rhythm some of
you guys know i do my sunday review and
when i do my sunday review i literally
go okay
where could i have shown up better this
last week where could i behave better
this last week what could have done
better this last week and i just reflect
on previous week
and identify the things that didn't go
the way i wanted to and i asked okay
what could i have done and then i do the
most simple and basic thing that you
could do on a sunday
i forgive myself
and i let it go a healthy response
is health
people ask me often how do i deal with
this well i go
be healthy
and what i mean by that is specifically
when you know you're disappointed when
you know you're sad when you know you've
got major setbacks you have to delay the
response to order 10 gallons of pad time
okay you just have to you you cannot be
like you know what i feel terrible so
bust out the three bottles of wine here
we go you have to delay the response
that is unhealthy
does that make sense
it's super easy i mean it's crazy easy
to when you are having a down day or
you're feeling disappointed to go oh my
gosh um
and go wreck yourself and get exhausted
so what happens you're disappointed or
you have a major setback you know what
you want to do
sometimes your response high performers
is overwork
you're sad so what do you do you
overwork
or there's a major setback so you know
i'm going to work 24 7 for nine months
and you basically kind of kill yourself
working and so in that way you say but
i'm getting ahead
no actually all of productivity science
and all well-being science proves over
and over and over again you compromising
your sleep and overworking yourself is
actually making your decisions
be poorer it's making your reactions to
other people be less sensitive less
helpful you're worse at negotiating
you're worse at closing sales you're
worse at effectiveness in your own time
of doing basic tasks your worst
everything everything that has to do
with leadership and progress and human
relationships you're worse at when you
cope by overworking
but that's what we do i'm disappointed
so i'm going to work harder i'm mad so
i'm going to work harder uh the business
isn't doing well so i'm going to work
harder but if you overwork yourself that
is not a healthy response the first
thing i want you to figure out is what
is the business or the brand or the
company you're really trying to build
over the long term
and i know that sounds like yeah no
doubt brandon common sense but many of
you you're entrepreneurs your stay at
home you're maybe a stay-at-home mom and
you're working on building that side
brand or that side hustle you're out in
the marketplace and maybe you're already
doing something where you're kind of
fully committed to it but kind of not
because you've got this other safe job
over here maybe you're somebody who just
started and you're not even sure what
you're supposed to be doing yet the
wrong time to hire is when you don't
know what you're supposed to be doing
yet you don't know the business model
and you don't know where you want to be
in three four five years it's really
important for you
to get clarity
before you hire
and i know that's so common sense but
it's not common practice
and a lot of people hire too soon and
then what happens is because they didn't
know the business model or they didn't
know what they really wanted
they got in a place where they had a lot
of team or that first virtual employee
that first assistant and they were all
kind of running around like what do we
what do we do what are we here for and
you didn't even have clarity on your
purpose or your mission or your ambition
for the business
and that's not where we want to be
because i think the most important thing
is when you're going to hire and build a
high performing team is that you have
commitment for your future
you have clarity when you are hiring you
are not hiring because you have a side
hustle you're not hiring because you
have a hobby you're hiring because you
have a clear mission
and your commitment to that is
everything because you're going to ask
people to come on your team
who they're committing their life
they're committing their day they're
committing their mortgage payment their
rent payment to you there's a
responsibility in you hiring that you've
got to know what you're hiring for
and that is so
critical i see people do that all wrong
all the time friends in silicon valley
they get a bunch of investment they hire
10 people they don't know what those 10
people are going to do they didn't know
the business model they ran out of
revenue and they had those people on for
a year or two and then they ran out of
cash and that'll let them go
i don't want you to be in that position
so the right time to hire is always when
first you've defined that mission that
goal that business
that dream for that three five year out
plan
and then you know that you're fully
committed and you're going to work it
and then you also really take joy in
leading and managing people because the
truth is you can outsource a lot of
things and not have to deal with it
or you say listen i'm going to make sure
when i hire i hire well i look at
everything i'm doing right now
everything for my business
right now and i go okay
of all these things i'm doing
which ones
will lead to significant growth
this
year which ones will lead to significant
growth
this year
everything else
everything else i start pushing out on
the calendar whether i push it out two
three four months from now or i push it
until next year
but i do a real close look at all of my
activities i look at my partnerships my
relationships i look at everything i'm
doing in terms of marketing funnels or
brand building or what i'm doing the
marketplace or what i'm doing in my
career and i go which ones of these
things are leading to significant growth
and if it's not leading significant
growth
i need to minimize that time
now i know you might say well what's the
difference between like a core three and
a significant growth rule
well the significant growth rule is for
the rest of the year right the core
three you already know the core three
are the three things you're already
doing to getting results
the significant growth rule is all these
new ideas people are going to give you
and put on your plate in august and
september and october november
everyone's going to give you some more
things to do right there's going to be
new opportunities and every new
opportunity or every new idea your thing
has to be at this time of year will that
lead to significant growth this year if
it is maybe you can add that on to your
workload because remember i'm just
asking for an hour here
maybe you can add that on
but if a project comes your way and it
doesn't lead to significant growth at
this stage of the year
and it won't lead the significance
growth the rest of this year
i'm out
i'm out so i turned down two or three
projects just last night from people
good ideas great ideas but i know those
won't lead to significant growth until
next year so i'm like
not till next year
because i know
that instead if i focus on these things
the core three
or other projects that i do know lead to
significant growth in other words
significant growth is a way for you
to prioritize and say no
i don't want you taking on any new
projects
at this stage of the year
if you don't believe they'll lead to
real growth by the end of the year
because you could just focus on these
more
right it's that old story of acres of
the diamonds you know people travel all
around the world looking for the
treasure and working so hard looking for
the new new thing and then they come
home and one day they put the spade in
the backyard and they dig up some
diamonds
right often
your next big breakthrough you already
it's already in your yard
you know what i tell people all the time
you've probably already met the person
who's gonna help you generate your next
hundred thousand dollars
your next million dollars
like you already met they're already in
your network but you're spending all
this time to go do all these other
things you all
you already met the person who's gonna
make you your next million dollars or
give you access to an audience or give
you access to an opportunity you've
already met the person
but you're out there searching for new
and you're accepting all these new ideas
and as you accept new ideas as a high
performer what does that do that crowds
out other things
and so from this day forward until the
end of the year
i want you to have the significant
growth rule will this project lead to
significant growth by the end of the
year if not table it if you want to
feel in purpose one way to do that is to
recognize
the kids are watching to recognize your
family is watching to recognize the
community is watching the neighborhood
is watching the world is watching us
right now history is taking note there
is a scorecard happening right now based
on how we are all showing up and for
some people that terrifies them because
like oh my gosh we're sharing up
terribly not me how about you how are
you showing up
one of the greatest things i've ever
noticed from the exceptional people i
work with in coach i mean like this is
like amazing people if i'm i'm training
a uh you know an oprah winfrey and her
team or i am you know talking to you
know some of the most
like powerful influencers in the world
or i'm talking with other people who are
just like
so we're all amazed by guess what they
always reveal a desire to be a role
model for others
when you desire to be a role model for
others it puts you into that pocket of
service in life
it makes you go oh my gosh
i i i want to not just live the best of
who i am that's part of being a role
model but i want to live the best of who
i am because i want to give others
permission to do that themselves i want
to share my authentic voice so others
can share their authentic voice i want
people to see me volunteering because i
want people to go volunteer i want
people to see me being kind because i
want people to be and live when we're in
a kind world that is the role model
mindset
you know and i so hope for you i i so
hope for you that you will adopt the
role model mindset this year you don't
want to go just have fun you have to
generate fun as you've heard me say over
and over and over before the power plant
doesn't have energy it transforms and
generates energy if you want more fun in
your life you're gonna have to generate
more fun you're gonna have to have more
of attention and intention to create fun
and silly and ridiculous and humorous
and just joyous
moments so what are some ways you can do
that well first and foremost realize
most great fun in life comes from an
immersion in the moment
it requires presence you know it's like
so many people are so their attention is
a million different places but have you
ever been at a restaurant and you got
your four or five friends around and you
all are just riffing like you're just
having fun you're all kicking around
ideas and telling funny stories and the
phones are off they're you know it's
just the four or five of you gathered
around or maybe the two or three of you
just gather around telling stories and
you're all immersed in that moment
in immersion
joy arises in immersion uh you know
humor can perpetuate in immersion in the
moment in presence of the now you have
access to a greater level of energy and
awareness all around you that now you
can really translate transform into fun
so you have to begin by having an
intention each day say i'm gonna be
present in my moments today i'm being
present in everything that i do present
in my conversations with people present
in the tasks that i do because in that
presence
more passion can come to a light and
more fun can be had it begins with
having intention to immerse this one i
forced myself to do here's what the 45
day quit rule is and it's hard for me i
hate this one
i look at all my big project ideas you
know i don't know about you but i have a
journal with all my big ideas in it you
know or my vision board or i have an
excel spreadsheet of all these different
ideas and projects i want to do and i've
got like you know right as an example
right now i know my next six books i'm
going to write
i know
i know my next three campaigns i'm going
to launch
i know them but here's what i have to
force myself to do and i don't like it
i say okay if this is a major project
that i want to do
even if it could lead to significant
growth
if i'm not going to start it listen to
this if i'm not going to start it in the
next 45 days
it's off my plate until next year
and
i push it to 2019. i literally just take
it from my journal
in my little bucket of things i want to
do this year and i put it out into 2019
and i feel so
mentally relieved
a lot of people have a lot of anxiety
about the number of projects they have
on their plate that they really want to
do
and so what ends up happening is that
anxiety leads to a lot of
procrastination
that anxiety leads to a lot of poor
prioritization because there's so much
to do they're like oh my god there's so
much to do here so i won't do any of it
ever had that have you ever found
yourself in front of netflix going oh my
god i have so much to do but i just
watched the fourth video in the third
season has that ever happened
you have so much to and that's the
problem you have so much to do that you
haven't prioritized what you are going
to do so you don't do anything
so what i do is this time of year i look
at all those things that are on my plate
and i get honest
which ones am i going to start in the
next 45 days
and if i'm not going to start the next
45 day
put it in 2019. now it's not even on my
mental concern it's not on my dashboard
no anxiety there no my god i still got
to get that one in nope it's gone
that's the 45 day quit rule i encourage
you to challenge yourself to try you
need to know what moves the needle in
your business and hire to that
not just what you like
you need to know what skills are
necessary for your future and develop
that not just what you're naturally good
at and this is where people fail all the
time
they're just trying to play in their own
lane but once you step into the role
of a business owner or you step into the
role of leader
it's no longer about just your passions
you have a responsibility it's called
stewardship you have stewardship to your
team to their mortgages to their rent
you have stewardship to your company now
you have stewardship to the future you
really have to step into the identity of
ceo
even if that's not what you're about
but i've learned so long working with
entrepreneurs some of them just never
step into the identity they need to
assume to win
they never stepped into i'm the ceo now
i'm in charge
so they're kind of half asset they're
kind of like hobby it they're not really
in that role where they've defined this
is who i am i'm in charge of building
this if i don't it all falls apart and
take it upon themselves to say i have to
lead here well i have to do well here
because if they don't do that
guess what
no one else is going to do it for them
the spark of motivation which is how i
anchor into being motivated each day
is ambition
all motivation begins with the desire or
hunger and ambition for more
whether that's more depth or more
connection or more contribution or more
abundance or more wealth or more love
like we just want
more of something and that says i want
to go get that like we see a fancier car
it's better than our car i want to go
get that we see like a deeper love of
relationship between two people i say i
want that in my own life sometimes it's
a visual cue something we see makes us
want something right
there not too far from here there's a
beach that i strolled on vacation
i don't know a couple years ago and i
said i'm going to live here
and it was a motivation it was a cue i
saw something desired it wanted it went
after it like so sometimes it's a visual
it's a cue out in the world that says i
want more of that thing if you will
realign to the core truth of who you are
stop faking it stop forcing it reconnect
with what your authentic passions and
desires are reconnect to your soul
listen to the whispers of your heart
realign to uh the authentic style of
living that you know is true for you not
doing it for other people
make sure you fulfill those aspirations
your being aspirations be the best of
who you are do things you're proud of
relate with other people in the ways
that you intend to create things that
you're proud of
make sure that you adopt that role model
mindset when you're adopting the role
model mindset you're activating your
full potential because you want other
people to see that you want to do things
of integrity and value in the world
because you want other people to role
model that themselves you're creating
the world that you want to be in by
living that you're activating your
potential you're being a role model that
will connect you with purpose you don't
have to seek it it will connect you when
you are in potential
when you are in potential and you are
serving
by being a role model and being of
service to other people not for yourself
but to be of service to other people
you are connected to purpose so you must
start training your mind now
to deal with stress
many of you that means it is finally
time to start learning meditation
it's like you've been thinking about it
you kind of meditate once in a while and
you've thought about it or you did that
one retreat one time i'm like
make it a daily part of your life
to center yourself
every single day
for some of you centering yourself that
just means closing your eyes
thinking about who you want to be
thinking about what's important
just calming your mind down other people
centering is like
like that can be just like if you're
super stressed lay down take a quick nap
for some of you that can mean like the
important self-talk some of you that
means meditation like for me
if i don't center myself every day twice
a day actively
the next day i know i'm gonna get short
with somebody i'm gonna let anxiousness
get to me i'll get my nerves i'll get
frustrated i'll bow out i'll quit it's
so clear it's like super obvious to me
that the days that i don't center
end up in tomorrows
that are chaotic
and so i just gotta
make sure i take that time every day
that might mean you take a 45 minute
walk many of you guys know every single
day i walk outside every day rain water
snow sleet i don't care i will walk 30
to 45 minutes outside
every day i don't miss because
that just
being out in nature and breathing and
feeling the wind on my face and the sun
just calms me down gets me grounded back
into the earth
and in nature it's like ah
okay
every day
so for what 20 plus years i meditate at
least once a day
i think for the last
14
maybe 11 years i've met a tweet
meditated twice per day sometimes it's
only five minutes both sessions
sometimes it's 10 minutes both sessions
and when i don't get that i might i
might take like a 30 minute nap in the
afternoon at some point i'll sneak away
even when i used to have a corporate job
and work for somebody else i'd go close
the door in one of the rooms run the
meeting conference rooms i close my eyes
for 20 minutes i meditate take a nap lay
on the floor do whatever i have to do to
re-center my mind first we're going to
look for in
a passion for what we do which i know is
very esoteric but you need to know it
right for our company for our industry
we look for people who are passionate
about personal development
professional development and growth
personal change self-help people who
love personal growth and challenge we
want people who have a passion for that
so we identify the passion related to
our company you have to do that too and
you have to be able to articulate it
because you're gonna look for it in
interviews
then for us because we're still a
startup we're you know under 40 some
people right our goal is
we look for the ability or the history
to deal with unknowns
and to get stuff done
meaning people who are adaptable
flexible who can come in and kind of
figure things out and get things done
they have an experience of either
starting new things or being on projects
where it was not super well defined
the company they worked for or the teams
they work with were fairly flat and
self-managed just people who can kind of
come and figure things out and get
things done
third we're looking for people who have
ownership to any failures or struggles
one of my favorite questions to ask
people when i'm interviewing one-on-one
is a question like um
you know tell me about a time when you
were working on a project that you
really loved and it completely fell
apart
and or a project that was really
important and it didn't turn out well
how did you handle it tell me about that
and if they describe that and all they
do is talk about how everybody else
screwed up and they were the savior and
uh then they're probably not the right
person
i look for people go you know what this
was a project to be working on it didn't
go so well and i want them to be able to
see like
i want them to go i'm bummed that didn't
turn out if someone can describe a train
wreck with no emotion to it don't hire
them so if you ask somebody tell me
about a time that you did a project and
it sucked and they're like well
and they have no emotion they're called
a sociopath don't hire those they don't
do good in culture okay you want to make
sure that someone has feeling and
emotion to something that failed in the
past
that that's going to have passion for
what you're doing i always tell people
one of the number one things i love to
hire for which is weird with my new team
here but i love to hire for this single
quality
guilt
i love to hire for guilt what i mean is
i love to hire people that i know if
they do a bad job they'll feel bad about
it think about it you wake up you grab
your phone you're like
you know
and all of a sudden you don't have any
motivation instead you look through all
this stuff and all it did
is make you feel like you're not enough
or it distracted you or it upsets you or
created you know anger or anxiousness
you got to be careful how you're using
cues to start your day
i use cues to start my day motivated
and those cues to start my day motivated
are things like i literally wake up and
i'll wake up and i'll think of things
that i'm grateful for and that i want to
give in life
i'll wake up and i'll think about
someone i want to do something nice for
or surprise today i'll think of
something i can be excited about today
all as soon as possible in the morning
fit revisit my ambitions list my goals
list i'll look at them i'll not wander
through the day looking at social media
and then oh i guess it's time to work
and look at my goals it's like my goals
i mean in the first few minutes of the
day i'm revisiting them and what i'm
doing is when i'm looking at my goals or
my gender or my schedule i'm looking at
i'm thinking okay
why do i want this what would life be
like like this how could i go get it
what should i do today to make that
happen and that motivates me that's my
list of goals my list of ambitions the
things that can excite me in other words
it's very intrinsic
goals it's intrinsic rewards that i'm
after i'm like if i go do that i will
feel better
if i could have this i'd be happier
right it's not that i can't be happy
with now but i want to pull
like if i can have that future pull
that's going to motivate me to go do
stuff right i have to literally generate
that in my mind and so when i have that
connection in the morning
then my takeaway for you is connect with
your ambitions every morning
very first thing in the morning
somehow part of your morning routine
connect with your ambitions look at them
why do you want them what would you get
from that how would you feel from that
what would that generate why would that
be more meaningful really connect with
that ambition every single morning and
you'll start to notice
you feel better is there somewhere can
you show me
on a wall
visually in your house not on your
computer not in your little phone
you know not on this one little note
that you tuck away and you hide from
everybody else so they don't see what
you're working on
no show me a wall
with your battle plan
see so many people
don't break through
and they don't break through because
what's end up happening for them is so
often they're in this place where you
know unfortunately the the truth is the
truth is they didn't have a plan
and they won't talk about it and they
won't say anything to anybody and yet if
you get down to it you start coaching
you start working with them you find out
they didn't have a plan
they did not have a plan
and so
i think it's important that you realize
the value
of having
your battle plan right so a battle board
what's a battle board if i showed you
your house you would have a wall
somewhere maybe it's a you know maybe
you wrote it on a regular eight and a
half by 11
or if you saw it in my room it's like i
went to i literally got like butcher
paper
and i take you know some blue tape
and i
scrap this thing
no i strap this thing
on this butcher tape across the wall and
what is on that wall there's 12 boxes on
that wall ladies and gentlemen what's on
that battle board 12 boxes
what's each box yep a month each box
represents one month and within that box
what do i have written down
the goals that have to happen that month
the metrics that have to happen that
month the steps i'm going to take that
month the key activities of that month
right there on the battle board you all
got it
so and i've seen a lot of these from
clients before i'll walk in and there's
their battle board you know and then
they might have a fancy one made of
burlap and tacks and beautiful instagram
ready battle board and here's what they
got they got their mission statement
across the top
and then they've got on there a reminder
of the three words of who they want to
be as a person you know enthusiastic
bold present
oh i like that then they've got the 12
boxes oh look in july
here's the numbers they're trying to hit
here's what they're trying to do in
august here's what they're trying to do
in september and on that battle board it
might be the most simple things it might
be in september
event coming up okay what are they doing
before the event here's the five steps
okay october what are they doing they're
taking the vacation here's what's going
on
but
visually
representing your battle plan
that's on a wall that you see all the
time
is so important did you look at your
goals every day this year
every day
did you look at your goals every day
this year
it's such a simple question
every day i don't mean once in a while
every day
and if you didn't my invitation to you
is to consider the fact that maybe
the amount of time that you're spending
with your goals is not sufficient enough
to motivate you
maybe the amount of time you're spending
with your goals is not sufficient enough
to keep you focused
maybe the amount of time you're spending
with your goals is not sufficient enough
to activate that unconscious brain that
says huh
i know how to achieve that
maybe it's the reason you're not coming
up with more ideas in the shower in the
morning because you're not cueing
your brain with enough
representation enough sorry repetition
of looking at your specific goals
because when you look at your specific
goals over and over and over and over
again day after day after day after day
it literally
helps rewire your brain and it helps
program your brain to say oh let me pay
attention to ideas thoughts and feelings
i have consciously and unconsciously
that might be able to manifest these
goals
this is why having a visual
representation of what you are after and
looking at it every day is so critical
to all of personal development training
of all time but why is it that so many
people still don't do it
they just get caught up more people look
at other people's instagram every day
than they do their own goals
and we wonder why so many people are
struggling to achieve things faster when
we lack motivation it is a slippery
slope to suffering
so please recognize that you must
cultivate more motivation
what else can you do
well i'll tell you it's like ambition
attention to those ambitions effort
towards those things i think all of that
is is really really really clear but i
also really believe that a lot of
motivation
is simply lost
because of fatigue
so let's say you're doing all those
things but you're wiped out you're tired
like a lot of motivation really rests on
how you feel physically if you feel
lethargic you feel tired you have the
flu
it's like it's harder to be more
motivated you can still do it by doing
what i've talked about re-cue yourself
reconnect with those things but
health-wise
it's really critical for you to say okay
if i want to be motivated long-term i
need to feel greater levels of mobility
and energy in my body so if you ever
hung out on me i'm constantly bouncing
and moving and breathing if you've been
with me at hpa you see some of these
practices this breath work that i do
that i'm activating and opening up my
body so that my body says let's go
versus
right so my body's not like oh i ate
this terrible thing instead my body says
i feel refueled i feel ready to go let's
go
focus on doing activities that draw your
passion
don't focus on the success the outcome
the final goal the final destination
a lot of our discouragement comes
because we're trying to make that
specific thing happen and we have a way
in which we think it has to happen and
let me tell you what i know a lot of
people who they actually did that
they they work diligently for years and
years and years to manifest their dream
and now they've you know they've
achieved the outward appearance of that
success they've got the bigger house the
bigger cars they've got the you know the
yachts the boats the fancy vacations you
know abundance in every single way and
they're unhappy
because along the way
they were focusing on those external
things
versus the activities that bring them
joy
passion and fulfillment
and what happens is you want to
compromise
on the activities that are actually part
of the dream
so that you can have the dream right
it's that person who works a job that
sucks for 20 years to finally get paid
something to finally quit that job to do
the thing they really wanted to do so
for 20 years they did things that they
weren't even passionate about
fooling themselves like well i just need
to save and save and save and finally
one day be able to go do my dream and it
doesn't really like make any sense
don't give up 20 30 years of your life
doing something hoping to earn the right
to do the thing you want to do start
doing the activities you enjoy and make
you feel
challenged or creative or satisfied or
fulfilled or on fire now
i think that's what's so important
everyone thinks the dream lives in a
destination
and i always say no no the dream lives
in the activities that you do today
are you doing today what you would do if
you had the outcomes you seek because i
know a lot of wealthy people who are
miserable in their lives they achieved
outward experience but they're miserable
because they're not doing the activities
in the day that actually bring them joy
and fulfillment
so if you need patience throughout this
journey the patience will come from
connecting with the activity every day
like don't wait to have the dream
do the dream
and if every day you touch that
like experience do you
you're doing that dream every day even
just a little piece of it then you don't
get so discouraged you know when you get
discouraged when you're just not doing
it but there's almost no dream that you
could have that you can't be doing
something
and touching that every single day some
activity every single day that is
actually part of the dream
you know i have a friend whose dream was
to become
a world-class chef
and so they were going you know they
were like saving all this money to go to
culinary school and they were having
like terrible jobs and they were just
like i'm gonna be a chef one day i'm
gonna be chef one day i'll be chef one
day and i hung out with this person long
enough to go hey man i know your dream
is to become a chef but you don't even
cook
right now
and like no no i'm working to save to go
to culinary school so one day i can be a
chef i'm like no no you can be a chef
right now cook dinner tonight in an
artistic fun way touch the dream now we
look for people who have a passion to
take initiative add new value we look
for people who have a spirit of
collaboration you know what the spirit
of collaboration always ends up being
it's two things number one
spirit of collaboration is enthusiasm
do they have enthusiasm for the job for
the gig for what they're doing does that
enthusiasm show through
like i always hire for enthusiasm but
then two collaboration requires openness
it requires openness to new ideas to new
people
and that openness when people have
openness they have a different way of
receiving and giving feedback
they're more in the learning mode
and so we're looking for that you need a
30 45 minute interview tops
like interviews should be quick because
you should know what you're asking for
by the time they get in the door you're
either you your hr company or the
staffing company you're working with
they should have already done the
preliminary work to see like when they
come in the door they're already
qualified like at a technical level or
an interest level like they should
already or project management level or
or you know
you see their library of work before
like it should be obvious that they
could do the job or they have interest
in the job so by the time they get in
the room
you're not really qualifying their
intelligence or their skill sets or
their personalities because frankly you
could assess all that before they get in
by looking at their resume by looking at
their library of work in the past
by giving personality assessments in
advance if you want to do that kind of
thing some of our companies we give
personality assessment in advance some
of them aren't we don't
so it's up to you
so
you have to imagine by the time they get
in the room
the whole point by the time they're in
the room is that's a few questions
to really gauge them on the things that
are most important to you so i manage my
sleep my diet my health
in ways that support my mental clarity
and energy
and i know that
like sounds sometimes people think
motivation is just a mental game i'm
like yes but your mind and your body are
connected if your body is lethargic so
is your mind right that brain body
connection is real y'all and i know you
know that you've been sick you've been
tired there's times when you've been out
of shape you feel terrible so i'm here
to encourage you as i always do if every
single month and high performance i have
to cheer you on to get in better health
to prioritize your health to sleep good
to eat well to move
if i have to do that every single month
i will do that i will be a champion i
will cheer you on i want you in
excellent health this year so please
hear me cheer that on every single month
because i just know i get you in better
health
i get you in better mental health
we get you in better mental health it's
easier to sustain that fire and that dry
patience is easier when you are
constantly learning
mastery
and what i mean by this if you've heard
me teach a lot i'm often telling people
make sure you know the five critical
skills
that you would need to develop to become
world class at whatever you want to do
i mean to become really good at what
skills
would you have to master
like for me i would have to master not
just writing but i would have to master
how to promote a book how to build my
brand how to run a business
uh how to communicate on video and
stages i had no idea how to do like any
of that and you can tell i still suck at
some of that right it's like it's not
easy but because on the way to become
best-selling author
i was always studying how to do all that
stuff
learning
can make you feel more patient because
you're like learning is giving you
progress learning is readying yourself
for that moment you get the big break
learning makes patients easier because
your mind feels more competent it's like
you know what i'm learning here uh
at least i'm getting some momentum maybe
you know the doors aren't opening maybe
the bank account isn't filling up
but my mind is getting sharper at this
i'm developing skill
and when you develop skill your mind
says hey progress we're doing okay when
the mind says hey progress we're doing
okay patience is so much easier it's
when you're sitting there you know the
people used to say twirling your thumbs
now they say playing video games
it's like when you're sitting there
playing video games all day detached
from the dream not doing activities the
dream and you're not learning
you really fall into complete detachment
from progress and now you just it's not
even a matter of patience you just flat
out give up
because the mind
needs
a sense of growth and that growth has
either come from learning or doing
questions like what attracted to you
what attracted you to wanting to work
with us
like what what about our company or this
role made you passionate about it tell
me about a time that you set a difficult
goal and you hit it
tell you about a time that you were on a
project or had a goal and it totally
failed how did you handle that that gets
to the points i made earlier who do you
admire the most
and why
i love that question because you'll
start to see people's heart come out
in an interview who do you admire why do
you admire them but also who do you want
to be a hero to or who do you want to
admire you
which is a really great question because
it gets people really thinking about
how they live their life and for whom
and it gets to a more personal level
often in interviews what do you think
would make you successful here
that kind of checks have they paid
attention to the company do they know
what they're applying to do they know
what your culture is like they have any
have they done their homework let's see
have you seen our website or what we do
in the marketplace do you have any
advice that we could already be better
like where can we improve what we do
what do you know about us what could we
do better give us some advice to see if
they're actually paying attention what
project would you consider
your most significant career
accomplishment i just like to say what
what's a project you've done that you're
really proud of
that was really the most important thing
and you hear and get to see their
passion and their enthusiasm and the
sense of fulfillment that they might
have we also like to say why would you
like to be part of this team
like what is it about this place these
types of questions they're not the
end-all be-all questions you could go
pick up any you know book on
interviewing at your local bookstore and
see and yes please go to your local
bookstore um and see like hundreds and
hundreds of questions
you have to know what are the questions
important to you
and that's it
that's it and if you ask the right
questions and you get the right vibe
then it's like okay because by the time
they come in the door they can probably
do the job
now in the interview it's all about
those things of can you see the passion
feel the heart feel the fulfillment see
that they're a good person see they have
enthusiasm about it see that they're
ready and they're hungry to do the work
see that they're confident we did you
know we've done interviews in the past
with some of our companies the persons
we interviewed they lacked like they
didn't really want to be there or they
didn't seem like
they would be good fit for a team they
were more of like the individual
contributor and they were smart but you
couldn't see that they would be like
willing to work with people you're not
trying to hire all the same type of
person but you or same type of skill set
but you are
as a leader and you should write this
down you're you you're not trying to
hire the same person
not trying to say hire the same iq
or personality
but you are trying to hire the same kind
of heart
you're trying to hire somebody who has
enthusiasm for their day for their work
the kind of heart that wants to do
excellent work
the kind of heart that wants to get to
work the kind of heart that cares about
other people so i was saying when you're
building a culture you're not building a
culture based on skill set you're
building a culture based on heart set
like are these people who care enough
about each other and have high
enthusiasm in their life and for the
role
and if you get that right you're going
to create some kind of magic and people
won't know the magic they won't know you
thought through all this
but all of a sudden they'll start seeing
it right right off the bat they're like
oh there's something special going on
here and it's because you hired for the
heart set not just the skill set
intention intention intention
for me i train myself on three words i
want to be and i'll remind myself just
remind myself those three words remind
myself those three words remind myself
those three words because it's easy for
me to reactive and be responsive instead
i want to be intentional
so know those three words that really
defined you and repeat those like
oftentimes when i'm if you ever see me
around and i'm like this
all i'm doing is i'm kind of rocking i'm
breathing in and out deeply i'm getting
attentive to my body and my posture and
i'm repeating my three words just to
reconnect because i do that every day
in the moment of crisis because see
moments of crisis it feels like
everything's out of control but what can
i control breath
body awareness what i say to myself
breath
body and errors what i say to myself i
do that over and over and over again and
it really helps me lock back in
i hope this supports some of you because
emotionally
learning to be centered emotionally
will so support you
as you go to change your life what is
fun for you
right i know that's so basic but can you
really think of i mean if i ask you
right now and be honest if i ask you
what are the top you know 10 most fun
times you've had in your life
do they come easily to you
see for most people it doesn't they're
like well that was that time that i went
on a roller coaster and i jumped out of
a plane or you know that time i was at a
wedding and i danced like a chicken you
know
like they really struggle and partially
what happens for people is they just go
through life kind of bumbling and
crashing around and they never have any
real reflection
on what brought them joy happiness
engagement enthusiasm fun so what i do
is when i have a fun moment
that and then i i'm a big journaler as
many of you know i i'm always
encouraging you at the end of your day
journal about things that you're
grateful for things that you desire cool
things or um inspiring things you saw
people say or do
you know just journal about your life
about philosophy whatever it is but i
like to write at night and i always try
to write also a component of what was
fun today
i reflect on what was fun so for me you
know i've got so many access points so
many references of what was fun in my
life it's just immediate that i know the
things that bring me great joy because
i've thought about them
so do you have your fun list things that
bring you great joy and great fun in
your life and you know what those should
be
your to-do list
because here's what people do their
to-do lists every day are tasks
not life
and that's why they're miserable
they've gotten lost into the minutia of
what must happen versus who they could
be
that day and that's where their life
starts to derail and they lose that
charge it's so magical in life so what's
your fun list
you know what are those things that you
could do that would bring great joy and
fun into your life and do them more
often and automatically you're having
more fun the very first move you must do
when you feel that coming on when you're
like getting whacked around and into
chaos the very first thing i want you to
always remember do is center in on your
breath
i want you soon you feel like angry
start taking deep breaths from the belly
and i want you to count those breaths
20 times
just just start like immediately start
counting your breathing if someone's
horri and screaming before you holler
and scream back and react
breathe the best way to center the mind
the body is through deep breathing
there's literally
thousands of years research behind this
in terms of both the the the more
anecdotal to what we now know in
neuroscience that deep breathing can
deeply calm the mind
and help you make better decisions so
just breathe
just breathe perspective you get
from time away from something
or
from other angles into something
and so the most important thing that i
can encourage you to do just like i ask
you to socialize sadness is to
share how you're viewing the problems
that you're having in your life or the
challenges and what i mean by that is
literally share how you're thinking
about it so if
you're struggling with something with
your team your business then go to your
team and say hey
can i just walk you through how i'm
thinking about this and seeing this
and perspective is not trying to solve
anything right this doesn't say problem
solving it says perspective
it means you share specifically with
other people how you are thinking about
something and ask how they would think
about it
follow me so it's like you know i i'm
i'm dealing with this loss in the
business right now
and uh it's really bumming me out
i don't know really how to think can i
just show you how i'm thinking about it
and you need either a coach who can hear
that
a
comrade a collaborator a colleague
someone who you know like and trust
who you can just share how you're
thinking through more often because
most disappointments happen because we
get myopic
meaning we narrow our focus
solely to the problem
and
in not describing how we're viewing it
we can't broaden it
and so
no matter what we have found in almost
all social psychology research in almost
everything that i know to be true having
coached high performance for so long is
that if we can get you sharing how
you're thinking about things and feeling
about things with others
and not trying to problem solve but just
asking how they would look at it
it actually makes you look at a
different way like here's what's been
going on here's how i'm looking at it
how would you look at it and they might
go oh
well i look at that like that's like
really great for you
you go what and like well
it gives you
time now to to kind of
restart
you know it's like
when steve jobs
came back to apple
he had
a very different perspective going back
to apple that he had when he was already
running it before but got fired
and that perspective allowed him to do
better he had to go
to another organization and start
another company and have a whole new set
of team members to help him look at
things differently that allowed him when
he came back to the same problem if you
will same opportunity if you will apple
he saw it in a completely different way
because he'd been with a different group
of people
considering a different problem and he
learned a new ways to think and that's
what we always have to do keep expanding
your ways of thinking about things
make purpose felt by feeling the data
create those meaningful moments again
create them just take a little moment
slow down time
when you're with your loved ones slow
down time when you're doing your art one
way to do that is stop being distracted
and trying to multitask and do 50 things
be in the moment when you're doing
personal development be in personal
development man be there with your
journal when you're when you're when
you're you know at dinner with your
loved one when you're on date night be
there when you're with the kids playing
be there when you're with your team
leading be there that idea of being
fully present again reconnects you to
purpose and suddenly it's not about what
did you achieve externally you just feel
purposeful you feel a life of purpose
because you are doing things that are
meaningful that are serving aspirations
that are serving as a role model that
are being of service to other people and
also you're just like i'm there i feel
purposeful even if it doesn't matter how
much you have in the bank or what the
car is like or what the house is like
those things are wonderful but those
things are also often a result of
realigning to your truth
i say it all the time
sometimes the universe or god or luck or
whatever the stars whatever you want to
call it doesn't give you what you want
because based on all of your
distractions and lack of discipline and
authenticity
it's simply unsure what you're asking
for
if you are asking to feel more purpose
you must realign your life to a life
that feels purposeful it's very easy for
me to be really effective in the
mornings and then that afternoon two
three o'clock and i could just be like
man
i want to go outside take a walk
come back turn on some netflix
eat some carbs
you know
that can be my afternoon if i'm not
careful so here's what i do i have a
checkpoint in the mid-afternoon
to recognize reward appreciate
anything that i have done today
anything that i have done today and that
midpoint checkpoint for me on my phone i
just have an alarm mine tends to go off
around 2 30 or 3 o'clock in the
afternoon it just flashes to me and it
says
what's been great today
what's been great today
and so that will cue me all right it's
time to visit what's been great today so
i'll just think about something i've
done it could be like i answered 10
emails today that i have been avoiding
good job
it could be as simple as i made that one
call i said i was going to call did it i
shot that content created that thing
whatever
some type like listen motivation is
often driven by recognition
so recognize what you have done so far
in the day
early afternoon
then what i do in order to keep myself
motivated even more because i've set my
mind i want to be a person who's
excellence driven
what i will do is i say okay
here's what's great so far and then i
asked just a simple question
how do i complete this day with
excellence just a simple touch point in
the afternoon how do i complete this day
with excellence
so i will look at the rest of the day
whether that's two hours more four hours
more five hours more six hours more
whatever it's going to be for me and i
go okay
how do i think through the rest of this
day with real excellence and when i can
connect with that i'm telling you
it's just it's just so part of me and it
really makes me want to serve so please
think about having a mid-afternoon
connection point to keep yourself
motivated you'll feel a whole different
quality of life come in i promise it's
it's a different experience for people
because most people they're just running
and gunning through the day they don't
realize uh or understand or accept how
challenging it is to lose motivation and
so they've gone many people they've gone
weeks without being motivated they're
going through the motions
but there's no energy there's no
emotional pull
towards something better and because
they're lacking that emotional pull
what ends up happening
they dog it they don't contribute as
much if you know
you're a person of excellence and if
it's true
i would not see a rhythm of crashing and
burning i would not see a rhythm
of burns and busts
burning out
failures
and exhaustion
and it's really hard because i know
trust me i like there's so many nights
i'm like oh my god
if i just stay awake for four more hours
i can get these projects done and you
know what and then i'm a complete idiot
72 hours later i know it will catch up
with me
those who play the long game don't
compromise in the short game because
they know it catches up later and that
ketchup is a devil
it is a bear it is a beast it knocks you
down and what happens is you oh
compromise three hours here but then
because that compromised three hours
here
you're knocked off your feet three days
over here
so if you'd taken the three hours to
recharge you wouldn't be worthless for
three days in the middle of the week
right i want you to have steady rhythm
that's what we call high performance
that ability to have long-term success
while maintaining your well-being
and your health my friends you so
deserve that double down on your
goodness you want to have an exceptional
and incredible 20 20 you want to find
purposes here double down on your
goodness
adopt the role model mindset and say how
can i be a role model how can i serve
how can i do more good in the world
because as i do more good in the world i
lift the world as i do more good in the
world it challenges me to be a person of
potential and as i challenge myself to
be a person of potential and i inspire
other people i feel like i am serving a
purpose
see when we send some role models to
others
purpose is connected in that very moment
when you know you're being a role model
your kids boom purpose is connected when
you know you're being a role model for
your team boom purpose is connected when
you're standing on stage and you're
speaking your truth boom purpose is
connected you don't have to go hope to
find it it's connected when you are
being
a role model it's connected when you are
activating your full potential it's
connected when you are in alignment with
your truth
you got it you have to go look for it
you need to connect to it what are the
skills you have to develop for me
that was video for me that was online
marketing including building web pages
starting newsletters sending out
newsletters building opt-in pages to
capture name and emails following up
with sequences automated marketing
sequences i had to learn how to do that
i had to learn how to do webinars and
all these other things not because i
wanted to but i thought am i always
going to do webinars in my business
probably better learn how to do them
not because i had a passion for it i was
like i'm always going to do them so let
me figure it out first try it out first
do some research there's plenty of
things online that will help me figure
that out and then after that then i can
go into
hiring somebody else because i can
manage it so first piece
develop
the skills
needed to win and if you don't know what
those skills are or those skills don't
currently exist in your calendar meaning
you're developing them then
then you're just going through the
motions you're winging it and frankly
you're risking your career
one of my favorite things to do to check
to see if i got a high performer in the
midst when i talk with people i go what
are the three skills you're working on
right now in developing
and if they don't know it i know they're
amateurs
that's just it there's amateurs they're
beginners and that's not to judge them
that's just to say they haven't stepped
into living what we call the high
performance experience the high
performance experience is all about
developmental goals it's all about
bringing our best and growing into what
we need to right your daily g3 journal
and review uh if you've heard me teach a
lot about down times before uh
especially the last couple years a
couple years ago the the g3 was the
three g's and it's what it means is
every single day i want you to journal
on these three
things and i do mean journal meaning you
write it down
in the morning and you review it at
night
so that's why it says journal and review
so you write in the morning
and review it all at night and so here's
what the g3 is the first thing you know
is your gratitude and that is just what
are you grateful for
why does that make you feel good
why are you thankful for it and just
write it down in your journal just a
whole like you should have a gratitude
journal already but when you're
disappointed or having setbacks i want
you to do the gratitude in the morning
a lot of gratitude journal stuff is that
the night i want you to move it right up
the morning like just you got to prime
your morning for some goodness so right
off the bat you got to do that okay so
gratitude second major thing i want you
to focus on is your goals
what are the specific daily and weekly
goals you're working on you got to get
really narrow focused
right when you're disappointed or sad or
set back
you know
the idea of creating a vision board and
seeing out 10 years from now that's too
much what you need to do is get really
close in your term this day's goals this
week's goals because you can check those
suckers off and get a little progress in
you'll feel differently as we talk about
so goals is important
and the third g is goodness
and the goodness is
noticing what is good from the previous
day
so when you start the day you're like
okay what am i grateful for in general
for life
what are my goals specifically daily and
weekly in each of these different areas
of my life you might have goals in your
career and your health and your finances
and your relationships and then the
goodness is what actually good did
happen yesterday
and that will just get you in a place
where you're like oh this day is going
to be good too
it's making you more mindful to all the
good things and the reason i do that one
last
and the difference between gratitude
gratitude's general things you're
grateful for the goodness thing
is to think about what good happened
yesterday and the reason we do that
because in neuroscience we know that
thinking about the goodness from
yesterday
is triggering your hippocampus to kind
of turn on and fire up and if we get
more memory activation off the bat in
the morning we actually have more
creativity in the day too it's weird
sparking memory is good for creativity
creativity is very good for coping and
so that's why i'm trying to get you to
reflect a little bit on something that
happened yesterday just to think through
find that mindful moment and it's also
teaching you to be more mindful through
of the moments each day not just
grateful in general but actually being
mindful for the good moments each day so
i want you to do that journal every
morning and then every night i want you
to look back at it
and
think about it and maybe repeat it if
you want to i just want you to review
the day and review those things
what was i grateful for oh yeah that's
right because maybe at the end of the
day the truth is you haven't moved a lot
forward
maybe you know your your spouse
or yourself you're still sick or maybe
there's still conflict or maybe the
business still because i'm not going to
be pollyannish and say everything
changes in one day and everything's
great just because you did your
gratitude journal you might be the one
today it still sucks so reviewing it is
going to put you back in that positive
mindset that's going to help you then
take the next day before you hire a team
i really encourage you
to either hire one person and the two of
you outsource a lot of the tasks so you
learn what that looks like because if
you haven't outsourced tasks before
you're going to be a pretty crappy
manager or leader
right if you just go i'm gonna hire a
bunch of people and you get them on
board but you've never actually managed
task assignment and task completion
it gets really hard so what i tell most
people if you're just starting which i
know many of you were in your brands or
businesses or many of you are
solopreneurs and you asked me about this
he said brandon what if i'm just hiring
my first two people what would you do i
see my first two people i might first
understand your skill sets
i might hire somebody to be your virtual
assistant or somebody to plug one
specific skill set hole that you just
don't have
but then the two of you before you hire
number three four five and six i
actually want the two of you or yourself
to outsource first go to like up work go
to fiverr go to something where you can
put out tasks as projects to people
and manage that
see how that feels
see if you like that see if you find
yourself going i don't really like
working with other people some of you
should never work with another human
being you're just you're horrible you
just should you should just know that
about yourself and accept that about
yourself step into that truth if you
don't want to lead or be around people
you know what you'll find that out
pretty soon as you start outsourcing i
really encourage you in other words
i'm sort of
imploring you
take baby steps
baby steps into hiring just baby steps
it it's like when you go to college and
business school they're just like well
start with hiring your team and defining
your culture and having a mission
statement values and i'm like that's
even fast for most people the worst
thing someone can do is go hire five
people and not even know if they
know what their business is what their
skills should be or if they like
assigning delegating and following up on
tasks
so first outsource and in general
most of the repetitive or simple tasks
that you have in your business you
should look for ways
to outsource that first before you hire
internally
why it's just straight up
basics of math it will always be cheaper
to outsource to contractors
and outsource to people who you have the
ability to hire and fire immediately
because they're work for hire
versus it's somebody who's on your
payroll who's a team member who you have
to give you know three warnings to
before you let them go
and especially if you're just starting
and you don't really know what the
rhythm
there is going to be for them to work
with you
outsourcing is great it helps you find
your tempo it helps you find what you
really do as a business
to outsource so i'd love for you to just
think about and you haven't done this
and you own your business or you lead a
team
to sit down and go okay what are all the
repetitive tasks that happen in my
business let me review where my week
went good and bad
and let me decouple my emotions from
that so i can enter monday with freedom
because when i am in a space of freedom
i make much better decisions than when i
am in the space of lack
when i am in the space of self-hatred
when i'm in the space of carrying all
this stuff unprocessed i mean have we
learned anything from personal
development other than hey you got to
process the stuff that went
that happened in your life and
understand how you identify with that
and what you're going to do next you got
to process it man and most people
because they're not processing
their immediate snap judgments of self
oh i screwed up imagine if we could just
loop back your last couple months
and every single week just think about
every think about how much you screwed
up the last couple months i don't know
about you but mine's like a like like my
hands would have to like i can't i don't
have enough hands like to count the
number of screw-ups in the last couple
months i can't it's like it's so
infinite number of screw-ups but imagine
if every time i screw up i'm like oh
you're screw-up ugh you're done brendan
and my self-talk in that moment was snap
judgment which most people it is snap
judging self talk dummy oh
i know this stupid brendan
imagine if we take a loop of that for
the last six months
uninterrupted unpaused unedited
and we took out all the situations of
life we removed all context and it just
sounded like screw up you suck you suck
you suck why'd you do that oh my god
dummy dummy dummy stupid stupid stupid
stupid and we didn't
de-hook that
we didn't decouple that
that's what most people's realities are
and because that's always running
unconsciously because they're not
deliberate processing
they're not living a courageous life now
because every time they think a
courageous thought
that overwhelming chorus of noise
filters and swamps and smashes
that that whisper of a dream
that is bold
is beaten to death by the rap base
of the horrid
talk that we have with each other it's
like
in the back
right
and so
that noise
needs to be
synthesized and edited down
on a simple sunday
you just sit there on your sunday and
you go
all right man
i had a lot of noise this last week
a lot of things didn't go the way i did
but you know what let me think about
them how could i have met those
situations as my highest self or more
courageous self what could i have done
okay good good brendan you're learning
good job brennan you're learning oh yeah
you could have been better then yeah
good for you having the intention to be
better good for you to learn brendan
good for you to set higher intentions
brennan good job being on purpose good
job brendan trying to improve your life
okay good job you really
you got a new way to look at that
brendan good job
now just
let it go man
just take that emotion and let that
emotion float away for a little bit
don't let that emotion from that mess up
mess up my monday
it's sunday
i gotta let that go
i forgive myself in that situation
because i've learned i forgive the other
people in the situation because even if
they didn't learn i learned and they
gave me a lesson
i let go of that situation because that
situation is not in this moment as i'm
sitting here with my green tea and my
journal reflecting on last week in this
moment i got a journal i got a green tea
it's just me and the green tea
so you see we've got this opportunity
to make a space
every week
in which we debrief the weak
and decouple ourselves
unhitch the trailer of weight
and let it fall back down the hill if
i'm having
some dark days and sad times i'm like i
got to get progress so what i'll do is
i'll identify my five major moves if you
read this book high performance habits
you know about the five major moves so
identify my five major moves and i'm
like i'll swiftly move towards one
because momentum can shift mindset
and so if i'm in dark disappointment
down momentum like achieve some goals
but here's what's important notice i
said the five major moves
that's what i mean with progress because
what a lot of people mistakenly do is
they just start doing lots of tasks and
activities that aren't correlated in any
way to the meaningful pursuits of life
so here's what happened
i'm bummed i'm downed so i'm doing a
bunch of work
the next day they still feel bummed and
down because what was their work it was
a bunch of activities that actually
didn't matter they didn't give them any
meaning
so if you're down
the most important working you'll be
doing is the ones that you do feel
connection enthusiasm meaning
fulfillment satisfaction from those ones
that do intrinsically bring you joy
those the ones that i want you to
progress towards matter of fact i really
want you when you're feeling down
disappointed major setbacks dark days
what i really desperately want you to do
is stop multitasking and doing all the
little like busy work things that don't
matter
like
like put off like
if it's wednesday and
you know you got a stack of bills and
they're not due
for another
30 days
don't pay the bills that day because
that's not fun and you're you've got
plenty of time to do it later when you
fee like when you get over this piece
this funk like just say okay write the
date on those bills pay them on but
don't do it today
because that's busy work instead today
find an activity that you find to be
creative compelling engaging fulfilling
and do that progress towards the things
that have meaning that's huge
when you're down
but most people don't do that because
what's comforting just like eating
comfort food
is doing low hanging fruit activity
i'll pay the bills and answer a bunch of
emails you know but those small little
tasks
those don't give you enough bang for the
buck to really move through it and
there's a big misconception about that
in the culture including the science
that often says oh no no just you know
if people can complete small steps
small tasks
they'll feel better
and it's like
well yeah i mean we all have this reward
system in our brain and little dopamine
will fall out but do we do we want a
little
drip drip of dopamine or do we want the
floodgates to come open and feel alive
so i want you to do the activities that
are more meaningful
not just like tasks
you know you've got
to start
creating meaningful moments in your life
what do you mean by that well listen you
and i both know i mean how many times do
you get caught up in the day you get
caught up in the news you caught up on
your you know swiping and looking and
looking and consuming you get caught up
in your to-do list you get caught up in
all the emails you get caught up in all
the work and all of a sudden the whole
day went by
and you didn't feel it
and i'm here to tell you something that
really remarkable that i've learned this
last year
uh you know last year was my first year
where as a high performance coach i was
coaching two billionaires and i'd never
done that before i mean i mean many of
you guys know and you've been with me on
my journey you know for what uh
two decades i've been in personal
development and in this last decade it's
kind of where i made my mark you know i
published six books uh we grew our
audience to you know whatever five
million on facebook and you know eight
hundred thousand whatever it is on
instagram now eight hundred thousand on
youtube uh best-selling books traveling
you've seen us fill the rooms and all
the events that i do
but this last year was like a whole
other level for me it was so hard so
challenging we we moved denise and i and
i also started taking on these caliber
of clients i mean holy cow i didn't know
i didn't know if i could handle it i
mean i'm not a billionaire i got no
problem telling anybody that i'm not out
there trying to pretend i you know
pretend uh you can't fake it with
billionaires they know
and
so when i was coaching them i kind of
struggled for a while to
figure out what they were unhappy about
i hope that doesn't sound flippant but i
was like
wow they got so much going for what
what's up why why aren't you happier if
you have everything right
like the material things most people are
seeking why aren't you happier and i'll
ask you guys that same thing
why do you feel like you're not happier
like
what's going on
i mean
most people consumer watching this i
mean you're doing okay
i mean you might be unhappy here and
there you you might struggle with like
especially i mean a tremendous amount of
our audience in personal development is
strivers they're achievers they're
working hard they're often the leaders
in their community and everybody goes
wow
they're already impressed with you
they're already happy that you're
chasing your dream they're already like
kind of like you're living your own
you're living life on your own terms a
little bit and so were these major
people i was coaching i couldn't figure
out what's going on with them and then i
finally i tripped on it maybe
it was last year the end of i think was
the end of the prior year
i got it
here they were doing amazing things guys
every single day they were living the
dream they had finances they they had
impact they you know people were
impressed with them they uh you know had
love often in their life they were
married or had good kids or whatever
but they still weren't happy and they
still did not feel connected
and here is what i discovered
they did not
feel
the day
say it again they didn't
feel
the day
they went through the day some of them
very high achieving through the day
accomplishing things on their purpose
making a difference a role model earning
doing the whole thing and yet when they
laid their head on the pill at night
they hadn't felt
the day
think about that for a moment think
about how many days you go to bed and
you didn't really feel
the moments of the day
and this is why too many days unfelt
leads to a disconnect with purpose
too many days unfelt
leads to a disconnect
with purpose
does that make sense
and so what we what do we have to do we
have to create the habits the routines
the patterns where we learn to create
and feel meaningful moments
it's i talk about this in my book the
motivation manifesto or you guys hear me
talk about on the brennan show a lot my
podcast where you you have to take these
moments in time and do what i call slow
time
it's like yes you're going to kiss your
honey
on the way out the door to work but you
know what when you plant that kiss plant
that kiss baby i like make it a moment
feel that moment
you know
when you hug the kids and they run off
to school like really give a real hug
don't like pasaya and move on to the
next thing we're always moving on to the
next thing and not feeling this moment
we're not present in the moment
because we're not thinking about let me
create something meaningful here let me
feel something here because we're absent
of presence
and the sense of meaning in the moment
we are disconnected from purpose now
i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker when you commit to a plan
of action of when and how you're going
to follow through when you write it down
you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you commit publicly to
somebody else it jumps to 95 chance from
30 something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you your
daily g3 journal and review uh if you've
heard me teach a lot about down times
before uh especially last couple years a
couple years ago the the g3 was the
three g's and it's what it means is
every single day i want you to journal
on these three
things and i do mean journal meaning you
write it down
in the morning and you review it at
night
so that's why it says journal and review
so you write in the morning
and review it all at night and so here's
what the g3 is the first thing you know
is your gratitude
and that is just what are you grateful
for
why does that make you feel good
why are you thankful for it and just
write it down in your journal just a
whole like you should have a gratitude
journal already but when you're
disappointed or having setbacks i want
you to do the gratitude in the morning a
lot of graduate journal stuff is it
tonight i want you to move it right up
the morning like just you got to prime
your morning for some goodness so right
off the bat you got to do that okay so
gratitude second major thing i want you
to focus on is your goals
what are the specific daily and weekly
goals you're working on you got to get
really narrow focused
right when you're disappointed or sad or
set back
uh you know
the idea of creating a vision board and
seeing out 10 years from now that's too
much what you need to do is get really
close in near term this day's goals this
week's goals because if you can check
those suckers off and get a little
progress in you'll feel differently as
we talk about so goals is important and
the third g is goodness
and the goodness is
noticing what is good from the previous
day
so
when you start the day you're like okay
what am i grateful for in general for
life
what are my goals specifically daily and
weekly in each of these different areas
of my life you might have goals in your
career and your health and your finances
and your relationships
and then the goodness is what actually
good did happen yesterday
and that will just get you in a place
where you're like oh this day is going
to be good too
it's making you more mindful to all the
good things and the reason i do that one
last and the difference between
gratitude gratitude's general things
you're grateful for the goodness thing
is to think about what good happened
yesterday and the reason we do that
because in neuroscience we know that
thinking about the goodness from
yesterday
is triggering your hippocampus to kind
of turn on and fire up and if we get
more memory activation
off the bat in the morning we actually
have more creativity in the day too it's
weird sparking memory is good for
creativity creativity is very good for
coping and so that's why i'm trying to
get you to reflect a little bit on
something that happened yesterday just
to think through find that mindful
moment and it's also teaching you to be
more mindful as through of the moments
each day not just grateful in general
but actually being mindful for the good
moments each day so i want you to do
that journal every morning and then
every night i want you to look back at
it
and
think about it and maybe repeat it if
you want to i just want you to review
the day and review those things
if you want even more motivation from
brendan burchard check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there ambition but too many of us
back away from it because it got made
bad right i was scared to have ambition
because you know what if you have
ambition too big for your britches
people start insulting you